Did you ever have an experience?
Podcast starts the same way every fucking time and that shit's boring.
I'm tired of doing it this way.
Brian came some music.
Want me to trip you out?
Music?
Just a little bit of music.
Just a little piano.
Just little something
we brought to you by a lot of things today we're brought to you by death squad.
Dot.
TV Desk.
Squat.
Dead TV is the official desk squad website where you could buy all the Brian red
bands,
trippy cat tee shirts.
I don't know.
People ask me what is the deal with,
why does desk squad associated with a cat?
I'll tell you why because I've got a crazy fucking employee.
I don't know what's wrong with this kid.
He's got issues.
He tries cats with Charlie Chaplin mustaches on the,
load it up with dynamite.
Look at this.
That's the logo.
What does that mean?
That doesn't mean anything but it means something and the new one is even
freakier.
All of them are available at desk squad,
Def TV,
all the money goes to a Brian's podcast network and a to keep this a studio
going and just to keep everything fresh and funky folks.
So,
uh,
he know that if you buy a death squad.tv shirt,
your money does not go to evil corporations and come see us in Columbus,
Ohio,
Columbus,
Ohio.
Was it November 11th,
November 10th,
November 10th Columbus go to death squad.
Dot TV and all the information is available up there and you can go check those
bitches up.
Go to a higher-primate.com if you want to buy some tee shirts.
But I think I'm out there.
It's all monkeys and mushrooms.
Yeah,
I'm a grown man.
I'm a grown man and I would tee shirt company with mushrooms and monkeys.
Yeah.
All right.
Where am my higher prime shirt the other day?
Yes he did.
Nothing's wrong with monkeys and nothing's wrong with monkeys on mushrooms are
cats.
It's um,
I'm a silly person folks.
All right.
We are also brought to you by on at.com,
makers of Alpha brain,
shroom tech,
immune trim,
tech sport,
um,
all the different nootropics that we carry.
Uh,
if you don't know an entropic is,
it's essentially vitamins that enhance your brain function.
It's all things that have been shown in various studies to give you some sort of
a cognitive boost.
And it's not just nothing like rain Manish,
and it's nothing like that.
Bradley Cooper movie,
which is calming for sure.
They're going to figure that out eventually they're going to come up with a
pill.
It's going to make you a super genius,
but for now it will enhance the way your brain works.
It's all fascinating stuff.
Uh,
different people's bodies react different ways.
No one's trying to rip you off.
So we have a 100% money back guarantee on the first order of 30 pills.
You don't have to return the product to just say,
look,
goes,
shit didn't do anything for me.
And then we give you your money back.
Nobody's trying to rip you off.
We're just trying to sell you the best shit.
And it's all stuff that I used way before I had anything to do with on it and we
continue that same thought process into our line of fitness equipment,
so the kettle bells that we sell,
they're all Troy kettlebells.
They are the best kettle bells you can get.
They're perfect.
They will last your lifetime.
They are not cheap.
We were essentially sending cannon balls through the fucking mail.
Giant cannon balls with handles on them,
but you buy these things and you literally never need to go to a gym again.
You need a chin up bar and some kettlebells and you're good and then get some
battle ropes for your conditioning.
All of these things are available at [inaudible] Dot Com o.N ,N ,
I t.
If you use a code name Rogan,
you will save 10% off any and all supplements that that does not work with the
fitness equipment because we say that shit as cheap as humanly possible.
All right,
Franks Amber Lyon is here and shit's about to get crazy.
Joe Rogan experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast,
my night all day.
Amber Lyon.
First of all,
welcome to the podcast.
Thank you very much for coming on.
You're one of our first serious guests.
You're like a legit human that was working for CNN.
Like we have credentials now.
Dude,
do you feel this?
Brian,
do you feel a change to come back and get a wiki someday?
You can get a Wikipedia.
I think this week I think we're going to make it happen.
But uh,
thank you very much for coming on the show.
I became aware of you because of the Internet and I became aware of you
specifically because of your interview with my crazy friend Alex Jones.
Oh yeah.
Alex.
I love Alex Jones.
Alex was great.
He had me on to talk about,
I mean this is a topic I'm discussing that is,
is difficult to get people to have you on to talk about it because they not Alex
though.
No,
not Alex at all.
That's fine.
We found more corruption.
I can't believe this Saturday if at all.
You have to love his passion.
He's a good friend of mine.
I love him.
Yeah,
he is so passionate.
And when you follow your passion,
successful following that's happened with,
with Alex.
He's so passionate that people think it's fake.
They think that the,
like,
he's like some sort of a CIA plant and he's like,
you know,
living this lie of,
it's like the idea of it
putting out,
I almost wish it was fake.
That because of like,
I feel I always tell them every time I hang out with them,
like,
you sure you stress me out or just stress.
Like,
like I feel bad for him.
I can't calm down.
He's always,
yeah,
he's intense when he's eaten hot dogs.
I need another old fucking hot dogs now.
Where's she going with those hot dogs?
Yeah,
he was,
uh,
we came with us to the UFC.
That's a great time with that guy.
He was fun.
Dude,
I have to tell you,
after interviewing with him for an hour,
he,
he's genuine,
genuinely cares about the direction this country is going in and he's willing to
put his neck out on the line.
Yeah.
Just like you,
you do Joe.
And,
uh,
and,
and that's admirable because you're,
you're seeing a lot of people just kind of shut up right now.
Yeah.
It takes the real heroes to really come forward and talk about everything that's
going on or crazy.
Be Fun.
Tell me,
are you freaking out of your mind?
Are you nuts
for folks who don't know the story?
The story that I got from the Alex Jones show is,
and this is a subject that I had been really curious about why this wasn't
receiving any mainstream coverage.
When we would see all this coverage,
what was going on in Syria and all this coverage is going on in Egypt and in
Libya.
But no,
we never saw anything on Bahrain.
And,
uh,
I saw some horrific videos that I found online of just the military
assassinating descent or,
uh,
assassinating a different people that were protesting.
And you,
you look at the video and you're like,
how is this not huge?
How is this not all over the news every day?
How was,
how were we not imposing sanctions on this country?
How are we not,
you know,
speaking out against this horrific show of just,
it was just horrifying to watch.
But it was weird how silent the mainstream news was about it.
It was like there was nothing,
and you ran into this.
Oh yeah.
I didn't an only run into it.
I was knocked over by it and run over.
Huh?
They just hire you thinking you're a beautiful woman.
You just want to be like a model who's going to read the news and you're just
going to shut the fuck up.
I think so.
And unfortunately I'm Greek and I'm a Scorpio and turned.
Yeah,
that's not good.
That's dangerous.
Super Dangerous.
I don't think they,
I really don't think that they knew I wasn't just a talking head puppet when I
was hired.
I was actually hired by someone who ended up leaving the network.
Um,
and uh,
and so,
so I think they were surprised.
Uh,
I fucked up.
They didn't see it coming.
I think in 10 years of people go back in and evaluate the situation though,
they thought you were going to be a female Ryan Seacrest and just run with this.
Well there's a weird trend,
especially in Fox News,
these gorgeous women reading the news.
I'm like that is such a sneaky trick because especially if you're a guy who
can't get laid,
like having a beautiful woman talk about anything.
So I just want to hear her talk.
I just want to just tell him.
He would tell him what's going on.
And so like what better way to program people for your right wing agenda then
have like the hottest chicks in a planet.
Of course.
Tell you what's wrong with the left and then also have them say weapons of mass
destruction.
Hello.
Damn.
And it worked.
You know,
obviously we ended up in Iraq and Afghanistan and they're continuing to bleed at
hot chips.
Propaganda is strong for sure.
Well tell us your experience cause you,
you know better than anyone.
You were working on CNN.
I saw some of the other stuff that you did.
That was amazing though.
Especially the thing,
the piece on the child prostitutes in Las Vegas.
It was hard.
I felt for that mom.
It was so horrible seeing that mom holding one baby,
talking about her other baby who's now 13 and is just running around as a
prostitute.
It was insane.
It was insane to watch.
So I know you did serious work for them and that's like,
so that was some really deep shit and it was a long piece.
What is it like to,
to go from that to just running into this wall and this one particular subject
that set you off this ball issue.
Like what was that like?
It was,
well,
for me it was really disturbing.
Um,
I was,
I,
it was
horrific because I knew these people in buffering were being tortured and abused
and um,
and systematically killed and doctors can be killing doctors
for taking care of people who protested,
who shot
for d for treating these people.
They got tortured.
Yeah,
they got tortured.
Some of them are still in jail.
These are genuinely good people.
A ambulance drivers were beat journalists.
One was arrested,
his body showed up a couple of days later,
just fill it full of of torture marks and,
and what really bothered me is because I grew up in the Midwest and I know how
the American people get taken advantage of and our tax dollars are going to this
Bob Rain regime to support them and they're the ones doing this to their people.
How much money do we send to Bahrain?
Every year we send a,
I don't know the exact amount of money,
but I know that we send more than a billion dollars worth of weapons.
We've given them more than a billion dollars worth of a weapons.
They're using some of these weapons,
some of this tear gas that they're using to systematically guests or people
which they are doing.
They're taking weapons that they're allowed to use,
which is tear gas in bird shot,
and instead of using those for crowd control,
they're using those to systematically kill their people and gas them.
And this is being made in Pennsylvania?
Tear gas.
Yeah.
They're there because it's you and approve southern,
literally dropping tear gas on these villages every single day,
all day long and night.
And,
and Physicians for Human Rights and Nobel Peace Prize winning organization has
been trying to raise hell about this because it's,
it's tearing up these people's lungs.
People who are asthmatic are dying,
elderly are dying,
they're suffocating in their homes and they're misusing this gas.
And it's a very systematic way that they're doing it.
People are having miscarriages,
women,
um,
some of these doctors are now connecting it to the tear gas.
Uh,
so,
so this is something that needs to be talked about,
uh,
urgently,
because these people as I speak right now,
they're,
they're being guests.
How many people have died from this so far?
So far?
They don't know it because they can't 100%,
uh,
you know,
say you were gassed in a couple of days later,
you die because you have a respiratory issues.
You can't 100% connected to the gas,
but so far more than a couple dozen people have been killed and they just
continually do this.
So just continually all day long.
Yeah.
And,
and I think it's a way,
it's a way that they're trying to suppress the protests.
Also a way that they're trying to,
uh,
to silence the opposition and get people in these,
in these neighborhoods to convince the youth to quit protesting because they
keep getting gassed.
His as a result of it.
What is our business there?
What is our business with Paul rand that we support them?
Well,
this means everything to us right now.
And a lot of people will say,
okay,
Bahrain is so far away.
What does it matter to me?
I always explain this to my sister because she's in that mindset.
She doesn't really know about the politics in the region.
Well,
we,
we keep hearing more and more about Iran and a potential war with Iran.
So we need,
we have a navy base in Bahrain in Bahrain is right across a,
there's a body of water separating bufferin and Iran.
So we need that naval base if we're going to go in and eventually attack you.
Ron.
It's very strategic for the u s that's why we have buffering is an ally.
Um,
and so this situation is a situation where the u s is giving Bob Green money and
keeping our base there and allowing these atrocities to happen because of a
potential war with Iran.
So,
so your tax dollars are going directly to
this regime.
Not only that,
covering up the story further gets us into some,
uh,
potential conflict,
um,
with Iran because you're not knowing.
We're demonizing people who we want to attack.
And then we're,
we're praising people who we want to keep is our,
is our allies who we really should probably should be attacking.
Exactly.
If,
if people knew
I wanted to stop atrocities in the world,
you wouldn't be looking at Iran.
You'd be looking at fucking bar ranch.
Exactly.
You know,
we were detained violently there.
We were thrown on the ground.
We had machine guns pointed at our heads and they tried to erase all of our
video.
Uh,
and this was about 10 a 10 minutes drive from the naval base worth.
15,000 Americans are living.
And,
um,
you know,
and they tried to,
uh,
to bury the story.
But,
but fortunately I was with another female producer.
We were able to hide these,
these media discs actually in our,
in our bras during the a detainment.
Yeah.
Um,
now that I look back on it,
it's kind of funny,
but at the time we were very worried about that.
The discs falling out is you're laying on the ground and you have a gun pointed
at your head and racing your video.
You don't want that just to drop out on the floor.
What do you say to them?
Oops,
I don't know where that came from.
My tits actually.
Dot.
Uh,
so it was a,
uh,
it was a situation that was just pretty eyeopening.
That's intense.
And you tried to go back.
Oh,
I've,
I've tried many times.
They won't let me back into that.
Would you go back after that?
Because you find a connection to this story as a journalist when you know
something's happening.
Um,
I,
he,
you're crazy.
In other words,
the people are really good people.
When you meet them,
you,
you just remember them.
You,
you hold,
uh,
a big place in your heart for them and,
and for,
um,
for their survival and,
and you feel duty to tell their story
in about the Middle East that makes these crazy dictators.
I mean that's really the last place in the world were dudes are still rocking
it.
Old School like that where there's like a king running a whole country.
There's only the Middle East.
And it's really fascinating when you look at human history and you find out that
that's where the original civilization,
the oldest known civilization as soon mirror,
that's where Iraq is.
So like,
so those people that are,
they're essentially the townies of the world.
It's like people in the Middle East that are like these dictators.
I mean they really are running things the way they did thousands of years ago.
They have never had to evolve.
They've never had to move on.
Like the rest of the world has its,
I don't think we can even wrap our heads around the idea of kings in this
country.
It's like,
it seems,
even though as our police state clamps down on our right start slipping away
every day with the more of these insane bills that pass,
I still don't think we understand what it would be like to be under the rule of
Saddam Hussein and having his Uday and whatever his other sons name those crazy
evil psychopaths sons are running around torturing and killing people.
I don't think we can even understand that.
I think that's almost outside of our range.
So as long as something like this,
Bahrain isn't reported on,
it's not talked about in the news.
We don't have to focus on it.
We don't,
we don't really,
it doesn't,
it doesn't register with us
and,
and we're keeping them in power.
We're keeping these dictators in power.
So that's another thing that I don't think,
um,
our,
our current government wants us to discuss because they don't want the people to
be outraged and make us leave.
And they don't want this protest to succeed because if the protest succeed,
these protesters are going to kick the u s out.
I mean the u s has a aided this regime.
And,
and oppressing them for decades and,
and so,
so that's another reason the US doesn't want this reported on in the mainstream
news.
Wow.
It's so crazy because I guess the idea is by not have taking military action
against someone like that,
you're,
you know,
what are you just turning a blind eye to it or what do you,
I mean,
how do you,
how do you continue to continue to send them weapons?
How's that possible?
It seems,
it just seems unconscionable.
It seems like at a,
at a certain point in time,
someone has to cross some line somewhere and just go,
what,
what are,
what exactly are we doing?
Like is it really that important to go into Iran that were allowing this country
to run like this?
Like what,
what,
why are we supporting this?
Like what are we doing as a country?
Are we completely about dollar bills now?
Is it just about controlling oil ports and,
and,
and pathways?
I mean,
that's really what the Iran thing is about,
right?
It's about controlling the,
about being able to get oil out of a,
what does that,
that,
that shipping route.
Yes,
there.
And um,
and it's about,
it's about exactly.
And it's not,
don't let people lie to you and tell you it's about,
they're worried about human rights abuses in any Ron because look what we're
doing in buffering in order to potentially attack you,
run where we're helping them oppress hundreds of thousands of people on a daily
basis.
So,
so if we really cared about human rights,
we wouldn't,
we would have left buffering long time ago.
We wouldn't be sending them weapons.
We would be in Mexico when,
right,
exactly.
And we're being in a,
and once again,
Joe,
this goes back to the American public being lied to systematically by the media.
And,
and it's a real shame.
I think so many people say,
oh,
well the Americans are stupid and they don't know what's going on.
And no,
it's,
Americans are being fed lies constantly,
all day long and,
and it really needs to stop.
Um,
it's,
it's a shame.
Now you were there,
you're inside,
you're on CNN now.
What was it that you wanted to report on that you couldn't,
what was the,
the exact censorship,
what did,
did they tell you what you could or couldn't say about it?
Yeah.
Well,
what happened was once I got back from buffering,
um,
they were surprised when obviously the Bahrain regime,
when we started airing this video,
cause we were able to sneak out with the video.
They thought that they had erased over a video.
Uh,
and so we started hearing these stories and at first it was great.
CNN was letting us air all of these.
Um,
and that was for about a week or so.
It was very easy to get covered on.
But then Barbary and started calling and complaining and their companies,
they pay
US citizens and US PR companies to do PR for them.
Uh,
the people can't afford that,
but of course the regime can.
And um,
and then,
uh,
eventually three months later we finished our documentary and we found out that
it wasn't going to be airing on CNN international.
It aired once on CNN,
us,
but never on CNN international to the target audience,
which is,
is the most,
uh,
the most viewed English news station in the region.
And so,
uh,
we need these people needed to see this documentary and it was an airing.
And,
and I've had documentaries I've done at CNN,
the dinner,
Aaron,
CNN international,
but this entire documentary was shot overseas.
And what really got me was my bosses directly above me or it were dumbfounded.
We would have phone calls and emails and people said,
I don't know why this is an airing.
I don't know what's going on.
Um,
my producers were very,
very upset.
I mean,
they had risks are lives to tell this story.
Our sources had risked their lives to Telsia and their story.
Uh,
one guys who worked for Doctors Without Borders has house was burnt down after
he talked with us.
And,
um,
and yeah,
I mean,
and our,
our main source and the documentary,
he's in prison right now.
His mom just died yesterday and he didn't even get to say goodbye to her.
Real,
real job.
He's in prison for the next three years.
And he's a peace activist who has a picture of Gandhi on his cell phone.
Um,
and so all of these sources that helped us film this documentary or punished and
harassed for helping CNN.
And so we still couldn't believe why they had an air that on CNN international.
And so I kept getting people writing me and calling me and telling me,
you need to look into this.
There's something going on here.
Uh,
they're,
it's a,
it's a much bigger story and seeing as how I don't have a family and you know,
I'm not tied down to a retirement plan or I really could give a crap about,
about the money.
Um,
I started looking into it and realizing the bub rain's actually a paying
customer at CNN.
They are literally paying the network for programming,
uh,
journalistically.
I don't know if a lot of people out there listening know about journalistic
ethics,
but we're supposed to be watchdogs on government.
We are not supposed to accept money from them.
Not only accepting money.
Okay,
that's different.
If you accept money and you air a commercial,
but they're actually airing our long programs on CNN,
paid for by the buffering regime,
not only Bob rain,
we're talking Georgia,
Kazakhstan and other,
uh,
other regimes.
And this has been going on for decades and it bothers me cause people are being
lied to.
So it's just paid propaganda.
Yeah.
They're,
they're programming unit for propaganda.
So instead of being the news,
they're there select pieces of information that these governments want Americans
and whoever watches CNN to see.
So they pay them for it.
Yeah,
they pay on illegal.
Well,
journalistically it's,
it's,
um,
I would,
if there were a journalist's police,
I would arrest them.
Uh,
but it,
it is legal,
but is it right?
Uh,
because when the air,
some of these programs,
Joe,
they don't let the viewers know that that's paid for by the government.
Right.
When you watch like one of those wacky fake talk shows where they're selling a
blender,
they have to tell you this is a paid infomercial.
They have to tell you when this,
this blender guys in his talk show showing,
you know how you make cucumbers slice,
releasing and stuff.
They have to tell you,
why don't they have to tell you that on CNN?
That seems way more important than the fucking blender.
Well exactly because it's shaping our foreign policy.
I mean they're feeding the American public this propaganda so that they think
everything's rosy and happy.
And in Bahrain when really the situation there is is horrific.
And if you look at one of these programs,
you can youtube it.
It's called I list Bob Rain.
They have their host to Richard Quest.
They have him live at the race track for a week in Bahrain talking about how
wonderful the country is and how progressive it is.
And he interviews the crown prince and calls him a reformer.
And,
and this is the same crown prince who was in power when troops shot and killed
in broad daylight,
these tanks to shot out into a crowd of protesters and just killed him in broad
day light.
This is the prince that two years earlier,
CNN was telling the public was great,
was progressive reformer.
And it's not fair to the public.
When you watch these,
the disclosures are so minimal or they're not even there if you go on youtube,
the videos,
you know,
um,
it's not fair to not only seen as journalists to our sources,
but,
but to the people watching because they don't know they're getting propaganda.
So this has been going on for decades,
decades.
For decades.
We haven't had real news.
We've had a mixture of some real news and some bullshit that's paid for by other
countries.
Yes.
And we wonder why we end up in Iraq and Afghanistan and these conflicts,
you know,
and this hair.
It is,
we're seeing it now.
Yeah.
Leaders are striving to meet international expectations for a high profile
football tournament.
Europe,
second largest country.
If you look up
the Ukraine,
I mean they're,
they're letting the Ukraine pay look up.
Uh,
I list bufferin commercial and you can watch the whole commercial and you'll see
not once in the commercial.
That's like progressive,
fabulous new.
This week we're talking about buffering.
You know,
it never says in the commercial that this is paid for by buffering and,
and so that's not fair to the people.
It's not,
it's not fair to view was beyond creepy.
How big is Bahrain?
Bahrain is about the size.
Bahrain is small.
It's about the size of San Francisco.
Population wise,
you can't say Bahrain.
Bahrain.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
It's like one of those words,
like if you commit to saying it correctly,
every time
a,
B,
h,
r a I n and m and also we can,
you can see a video of these protests.
They're insane.
You watch them and you just see miles of people protesting and,
and then you really realize this is a true revolution they're trying to have
there,
but it's being oppressed by the United States.
Um,
because you know,
if the people get in power,
they're going to kick the U s out there.
Very upset because the US has,
has kept a regime in power for,
so we're helping this creepy fuck by giving them $1 billion worth of weapons use
tear gassing people to death.
Oh yeah.
Wow.
And,
and not only that,
they're systematically getting it off the,
the news in the u s as,
as what happens to me it was,
it was,
it became nearly impossible to cut through the red tape.
Well,
this is really disturbing.
If you had any hope whatsoever that we were going to avoid some sort of conflict
with Iran because it seems like that is just there.
They are dead set on it.
That's why another reason I came forward urgently,
because this is about much more than Bahrain and the systematic cover up of
what's happening about rain only tells you what's,
what's potentially going to happen in the future and,
and,
and in the near future.
And that's,
uh,
an attack on Iran or potentially some people,
if you,
if you go to the far side who have really analyzed this could say this could
potentially become a world war three,
Jesus Christ and it's all just to control oil,
right?
I mean,
is that what it's about?
it's just a control oil and it's just,
this is the way they've always done it.
So they're going to continue to do it this way,
even though now people are paying attention finally for the first time in human
history.
Yeah.
Well,
they're going to tell you if you talk to people who are very pro Israel,
um,
and,
and once again,
I don't have an opinion on,
on any of that area.
I try to cover that objective.
Lee,
I've,
I've covered stories in the West Bank and in Israel,
but they're going to tell you that Iran,
uh,
often deny God said he will wipe Israel off the map and they're going to repeat
that over and over because that's there for ward propaganda that they're going
to start feeding to you.
And they already have for years.
And actually if you go back to that speech that they're referring to aqua
dinners,
I'd never said that it was mistranslated,
but instead they rolled with that in the US.
Media has continued to roll with that watch Erin Burnett show.
Yeah,
I've seen the,
uh,
the original,
when they went,
it's translated correctly.
It's a totally different meaning.
It wasn't that we were,
but it was,
it wasn't nice,
but it wasn't the same thing.
Exactly.
I think it was in response to if Israel attacked Iran,
you know,
we would wipe them off the map or something along those lines,
wasn't it?
I'm saying that he,
they want the regime out of Israel.
They want that government out.
It was more a rhetoric then than physically like we want to go in and murder you
all and kill you.
It was more w we want you to be,
be kicked out of office.
So we sort of have equated it to like Khrushchev banging his heel,
you know,
saying we will bury you like that.
That's sort of a thing that's like,
so we've,
we've decided to run with that as the big threat.
Yup,
exactly.
And they say it's,
it's,
if Iran gets a nuke,
they're going to send it right in and wipe Israel off the map.
So that's what they're trying to use that for.
And everyone needs to pay attention.
It is,
it is propaganda.
It is forward word.
It's just like weapons of mass destruction.
I see them now.
Now that I've been in inside,
I know how they start feeding propaganda and this is exactly what they're doing
was saying,
well it will be,
Ron's going to wipe Israel off the map so we need to go in and attack and,
and,
and I mean this could potentially get us into a conflict with much more
permanent and damning implications then than Iraq and Afghanistan ever,
ever wore.
Yeah.
It seems like this would be huge.
This would be much bigger if we actually wanted to.
I run,
it's a,
it's another level of civilization above what was going on in Afghanistan and in
Iraq and theirs does no reason for it.
It doesn't make any sense.
There's no way the rest of the world is going to tolerate it.
It's gonna be,
it's gonna be chaos.
Yeah.
We have Russia and China to worry about as well.
If we go in and,
and,
and Lord knows what can happen from there.
I just hope that the American people realize that they are being fed propaganda
with,
with the Iran situation now in the same people behind Iraq,
same forces are behind this push to get us in Iran.
Did you see?
Of course he did,
but what did you think when you saw the Netanyahu cartoon?
When he's explaining with his fucking Wiley Coyote?
You know what?
I wanted to laugh,
but it was,
it was so sad because I just see the logic that the lack of logic and how
they're actually able to,
to get that to work.
He's just saying,
okay,
you guys are children,
so I'm going to draw you a child's cartoon and see,
I can't explain to you this.
I'm going to show you on the fake bomb that no one's ever seen a bomb.
It looks like that.
That's a bomb from a cartoon.
I mean,
it's so weird that they chose that
image for this like really ridiculous propaganda.
Oh,
you know what that tells you,
Joe,
that tells you what they think of the intelligence of the American public.
That that they think he could go up with some stupid ass cartoon and and try to
feed us that bullshit to get us into another war.
I mean does,
does he think that the American public,
is that,
is that stupid?
Did you see the lobbyist for Israel who was a thinly veiled,
trying to promote some sort of a false flag event who was talking about what we
need to do?
We need to have a green light to start our war with Iran and it's just like we
needed Pearl Harbor to happen for us to attack Japan.
We need the Gulf of Tonkin.
He's the Gulf of Tonkin,
which is a known false flag event.
I mean it's been proven that the Gulf of Tonkin,
there was,
the whole thing was a big fake story to in order to get people to be excited
about going to war in Korea or a nun and a Vietnam.
And he was talking about that as if it was like some sort of a,
an actual historical event.
Like to bring it up like that in 2012 it's either you have to either plead
extreme ignorance or you've got to say that this is a thinly veiled statement
that we need another false flag event because we're going to go into Iran no
matter what.
So let's just pretend Iran tried to blow something up and go fuck him up.
And they did try to do that in 2007 and perhaps the most hunted a whistleblower
is not Julian Assange,
just,
it's a woman named Gweneth Todd who worked for in the administration.
She was an advisor to the military and she actually blew the whistle on a 2007
false flag event,
uh,
where they were going to try to do exactly that.
Um,
that was bushes.
Last thing before getting out of office,
they wanted to take out Iran and she blew the whistle and potentially saved
thousands of lives.
Now she's in Australia hiding.
Uh,
well no,
you just gave her up.
Now they know that she's in Australia.
No,
no.
Uh,
there was a story done on it.
A couple of stories guys.
I'm not trying to,
not trying to get her in trouble here.
Um,
but she,
she's a real hero and that,
and that did,
they did try to do that in 2007.
What was the false flag event though?
It's,
it's funny when you save the two,
like who exactly is it that's doing it?
Like how many people are involved in something like that?
Well,
that's what worries me is because when it says that the same forces behind that
and Iraq are now behind the current push to get into Iran.
And I trust her because she risked everything to come forward and,
and reveal that and now is in hiding in Australia.
And,
um,
I don't know all of the details about it,
but I do know that they were,
they were going to try to make it look like,
um,
Iran had had blown something up or a attacked,
uh,
one of our us basis.
I don't know exactly.
Listen to me rambling.
I,
yeah,
if you look it up,
it's called,
um,
uh,
if you just look up,
just look up Gwyneth Todd.
Hi.
Spoke one of the Gw,
y n e t h and then t o d d to do,
I won't even let me,
it just says,
do you mean Paltrow?
Yeah,
of course.
That's what would come up.
You know,
Google's trying to,
trying to fucking,
yeah.
Um,
it's a pretty,
an unbelievable story.
I tweeted about it.
If you go to add amber Lyon and scroll down somewhere down in my timeline,
I tweeted
back a couple days ago.
She was a US senator,
I guess.
Huh?
Um,
no,
no.
I'm sorry.
This is a Patrick Leahy and US senator who is,
I guess there's responding to what she revealed.
Yeah.
And he's saying that there should be an investigation of the false flag terror
plot.
Yeah.
And it was huge.
I mean this,
this was,
they were going to try to start,
start a war with Iran with this,
and this was a u s making up lies and they,
and,
and one thing they were going to do is use these protesters in buffering and
make them also look like terrorists.
And this attack had it succeeded and it would've worked because most people
haven't been to Bahrain.
They don't know if these people are extremists,
right?
They're terrace.
How did we get to be such a nation of cunts?
What,
what went wrong with us?
Because that's not what the American people,
if you talk to the average American person,
they think of what is America?
Well,
America is about freedom.
We're about,
you know,
carving your own path.
We're about,
well,
how did we get to be this nation of people that are led by these really evil
corporations?
I mean,
that's essentially what the military is.
If you look at the military,
it's,
it's something that the banks and the people that are in power,
the people that put presidents in power or using in order to force their
corporate agenda,
it's all about controlling some resource.
You know,
extracting some resource,
controlling some areas.
That's all it's about.
It's not as nothing like whenever they call it defense,
it's so offensive.
Cause like,
what are you defending us against your out there fucking people up.
Like it almost has nothing to do with defense.
It has everything to do with offense.
If you say the best defense is good offense,
well then I,
I guess maybe you can call it defense,
but it's not what we think of ourselves.
We don't think of ourselves as this horrific force that's destroying,
you know,
parts of the world in order to control its resource.
We don't think about that at all.
We think of ourself.
Most people like to think of America as a fucking eagle or something.
You know,
we like to think of ourselves as proud people who,
you know,
can you come here and anybody can make it and just there's no caste system here
and you can really work hard and get ahead and hello,
fuck did we become this nation run by assholes.
It's just,
it's weird.
I know.
And it's,
it's weird when you wake up at that moment and realize,
oh my God,
you've been lied to almost all of your life about about certain things that are
happening in this country.
Is it just that we have too much power as this is,
there's too many American military bases.
There's too many areas we control.
Is that what it is?
Is that,
is it,
we just too greedy with it?
You know,
I,
I don't know exactly what's behind this but,
but I do know that,
I mean if you look at Nda and things that have happened over,
just I know just in my career over the past decade,
I covered the oil spill.
I've covered the nuclear industry,
the all the wars and really getting into it.
I started,
the more I analyze it,
the more I think we've really lost control of the country that people have.
It doesn't seem to be about the people at all.
It seems to be about having the legal means to squash any dissent anywhere they
want and that's in place now because of NDA,
which some people don't understand.
Keep rallying against it,
talking about it like,
God,
why are you so freaking out about this?
Well,
this is why.
Because they can essentially throw you in jail.
You can't call your lawyer,
you have no trial.
The,
they can do whatever they want with you.
Now if there is no rights anymore,
it's essentially they put into law that they are just like a king.
I can do what a king wants to do.
Now this is Bradley Manning Guy who pulled the,
pulled the plug on Wiki leaks and the guy who distribute all the information to
them or the who blew the whistle rather he pulled the plug?
Well,
no,
he gave them,
he gave him those documents.
He's in.
He's in solitary confinement and they've,
they've had him there for years now.
They're not gonna do shit with them.
They're just got to let them rot,
you know,
they've got barely feed them and keep the lights on and let them go.
Crazy.
Good luck.
You know,
that's,
that's America.
That's America.
If you,
if we,
you expose the bad things that we've done,
we're going to do a horrific thing and literally torture you for the rest of
your life.
And that's torture.
24 hours a day of light,
you know,
no,
no people to talk to and no booth books to read.
Just just you by yourself.
Good luck.
And that's another story.
It was really difficult to cover a stories of leaks and,
and stuff.
Uh,
what while I was at CNN and overall and in general,
uh,
because of Obama's Warren whistleblowers and journalists.
Now,
isn't that amazing?
When you think of Obama,
you think a guy that everybody thinks of as this really progressive guy?
Well,
he's a socialist Steven.
You know,
he's a guy who just had a single mom and it was raised in very,
very moderate family.
You know,
it didn't have money and it really made his own way.
Very intelligent guy made through Harvard.
And here he is doing some of the worst shit to this,
to the constitution,
to the,
to the the principals this country's founded on that has ever happened in our
lifetime.
And this guy's doing it.
And this guy is going after whistle blowers in a way that even Bush and,
and journalists,
he right now,
and he's been subpoenaing journalists for their sources and he's gone after more
journalism,
was the blowers in any other president in history.
And including one journalist James Rise in of the New York Times,
a Pulitzer prize winning journalist.
He's gone after him with subpoenas to try to get him to reveal information about
its sources as journalists.
We don't give up our sources.
I mean,
that's a number one rule.
So,
and in effect,
he's turned journalism into,
uh,
a criminal behavior and turned us into criminals.
And,
and,
and that's,
uh,
for me that's,
it's terrifying because if someone comes to me and leaks a document that's vital
to the public good that we need to know about in order to fix our government,
uh,
then I become a target too because they come after me and Nda.
That's another fear.
They have a fear.
It will be used against journalists because they will,
because we're not giving up our sources.
They will consider us to be aiding terrorist or terrorism and,
um,
and,
and lock us up as well.
And I think there's a lot of fear amongst the investigative reporters,
investigative reporting community that this could happen under Nda.
So you're at CNN,
all this is going down and you're,
you're,
you're realizing that your piece has been pulled from the international arm of
CNN and w what is a,
what is the next step?
What do you do?
Do you,
do you start asking questions?
Do you try to poke around or is it,
uh,
and what,
what kind of a atmosphere is CNN like when it comes to this issue?
Yeah,
I did.
I,
I went,
um,
on,
on behalf of my crew and I went in and made a meeting with the head of CNN
international,
Tony Maddix.
And um,
and not a lot of people do that.
Uh,
and my crew was,
was,
uh,
I just saw the looks on their faces.
They were very upset.
Um,
so I met with him and he didn't give me any answers as to why it never aired.
I met with them twice.
Did he say,
what was his response when you asked him?
Why didn't it get aired?
Heard
the first time he said he'd get back to me and then he never got back to me.
So I made an appointment months later.
And at that point he questioned me as to why a,
a well known New York Times reporter,
Nick Christoff had tweeted about the fact that they never aired the documentary.
He tweeted something to the effect of CNN,
why didn't you air amber lions?
I revolution documentary intimidation.
I'm suggesting that Bahrain had intimidated CNN.
It's not airing it.
And so he only questioned me about that.
And a more of a kind of condescending,
you better not be talking kind of way.
Uh,
and then I,
um,
eventually our unit was dissolved at CNN,
so I was forced out.
They just all do our documentary and investigative unit.
And,
um,
and I kept having this in the back of my head,
like,
you know,
when you can't sleep at night because you know,
something is going on.
And I didn't know how to come out and tell people about it because it's,
it is a very,
um,
I had to get all my ducks in a row because time Warner is a very powerful enemy
to have a against you.
Um,
and,
and so finally,
when I came out and I,
I just to test the waters mentally,
I tweeted about the fact that they had,
um,
sensor the documentary.
And then right away my agent was called.
Um,
and I was told,
uh,
on behalf of all the main executives at CNN my age,
I was called in and told on behalf of these executives,
you need to be quiet or you're gonna lose your health insurance and your
severance.
And at that point when I knew,
when they called to threaten me,
I knew that,
that I had to come out with this full fledge because,
because at that point it solidified that they're,
they're trying to cover something up and shut me up.
Wow.
So creepy
movie.
It's,
um,
who,
who would be the star of this movie?
John Cusak.
Yeah.
I think John Cusack would be like a guy who you work with in the office.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I wouldn't offend you like that.
How dare I'm thinking about who would play you.
I guess you could go with Jennifer Aniston,
Oprah,
but she,
Jennifer Aniston is a little long in the tooth for you.
We need,
which is still pretty hot,
long in the tooth.
She goes,
well,
how old are you?
Are you vote?
Let me gas.
I was going to be 28 you're,
you're right.
I'm 29.
Oh,
San Diego.
Jennifer Aniston is gorgeous,
but she's 40 you know that's creepy.
Was an older lady play you?
It was like this.
You'd watch the movie like this,
but just not 28 the fuck is going on.
You know,
I've been compared to a Claire Danes on homeland.
I haven't,
I've never watched that show.
But every once I showed you don't know if that would work.
You're a more attractive version.
That really annoying check that's in a lot of movies.
It was for the one from the Dr TV show.
The fuck's her name,
the one who was in the movie with um,
uh,
Seth Rogen where he got her pregnant.
Oh.
Oh,
Katherine Heigl.
There you go.
Yeah.
She seems a little annoying.
Really?
Not really.
It just the type it sheets.
It's not her.
I'm sure she's a great person.
Just the type of movies.
It's always these wacky,
romantic,
oh,
she's got handcuffs dangling from her finger.
She's a rascal and this guy,
they're not going to get together wall,
but maybe they are
really serious plots there,
you know?
Yeah.
They look brutal.
Have you ever worked with the vice guys before?
Or like if I vice.com
I am a fan of their work.
I do like,
I like the stuff that they do.
I like their style of reporting is very candid.
It's,
I mean
that's been one of the suggestions.
It keeps coming up over and over on Twitter and people are like,
you got to get amber together with the vice guys cause they can sneak it back
in.
They don't give a fuck.
They'll drop you from an airplane and a and to Bahrain.
Yep.
Yeah.
I've been trying to figure out how to get back in there.
I can't give,
I go,
you're crazy.
You need to stay out of there.
They're going to kill you.
I was thinking if I,
if I borrowed a friend's passport and then you know,
my hair brown,
but I don't think it would work.
Or You can talk about it on the Internet now that I'm letting them know exactly
what you need is like one of those Eddie Murphy,
big Mama Body things,
big fat body suit.
I smell sex change.
Eddie,
Eddie Murphy.
When he had that,
uh,
the big suit on what move we was at,
big mamas.
Black guys have done that.
God Damn it Martin.
Lawrence does that shit.
He's got the Big Mama,
right?
Isn't Martin Lawrence Big Mama?
That was a good movie.
It's not that I'm dissing on it.
I'm saying it's a weird phenomenon that these black dudes will,
were these giant black woman outfits and a black dude would pretend to be a
black woman,
an older black woman.
It's like Super Common Medalia and that Tyler Perry guy,
period.
Nonstop.
That's what he does.
He's a guy and he pretends to be an old black woman.
It's weird,
but it's a black thing.
It's Chris and Chris,
not Chris Rock.
Um,
I think,
uh,
Dave Chappelle was,
was talking about how strange that is once in an interview.
It's strange.
It's very strange how many versions there are of it,
you know,
like Jamie Foxx and in living color member,
he was that crazy.
Uh,
crazy black woman.
Yeah,
that was,
that is that,
I don't know.
Gosh,
I think that was,
I think that that was what it was.
But yeah,
that's a weird phenomenon.
You know,
there's not a lot of black guys that pretend to be women.
It's like Robin Williams.
Mrs Doubtfire was like the last one I can remember what other dudes,
white dudes pretended to be women.
Not that many.
Right?
Um,
Robin Williams.
Mrs Doubtfire.
Yeah.
MMM.
What was the show with Tom Hanks?
Bosom buddy buddies.
Yeah.
That's might be the last time.
And then there was white girls,
but that was the Wayans brothers.
They pretended to be girls.
Right?
I don't know how the fuck we got on this tangent.
I don't think that's going to work though.
I don't
picture you in a black.
That's a big black woman.
Do you think you'd do a big black woman voice?
Like say welcome to Bahrain.
Why are you here?
What'd you say?
I'm just here to check out Joe Country Holiday.
I heard you got a beautiful country up in here.
Oh,
that's terrible.
That's a white woman under there.
Pull that rubber off.
This shit is not real
impersonations.
Always about end up becoming Spanish.
Pretend that you don't speak English.
I bet they don't speak Spanish.
I bet you know you get fucking fudge your way through the whole experience fee
request though.
She doesn't have a voice like choice.
She looks,
do you find that,
uh,
knowing Spanish,
you realize how perverted all the Mexicans here?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
I have the best story about that.
Not only that,
and so I grew up in the Midwest,
so the middle of the country where no one speaks Spanish,
uh,
Saint Louis,
Missouri.
And uh,
and so I was at a restaurant,
there were all of the,
a lot of the staff speaks Spanish very loudly because they know no one in Saint
Louis,
no Spanish.
And one time I'm sitting there and I'm ordering food and I hear the guys talking
about my body and breasts and everything else and clearly understand it.
And,
and toward the end I let them go on for a couple minutes and toward the end I
turned to them and I said,
ah,
Kate,
three stake a DNS when a bad gap again.
Yeah.
Which really means how sad that you have a small penis.
And they laughed so hard.
They were throwing stuff around the room and I really got them.
And that's kind of the way I do it.
Like,
if I hear something,
I'll turn it and I'll just say that kind of slide to them and then they get a
laugh out of it.
And then maybe you know,
in the future the people speak their language,
especially Spanish.
That's a pretty common one.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
That's one of the most common second languages that totally,
totally,
yeah.
It's gotta be a weird thing to be able to just yell shit out and nobody
understands what you're saying,
you know?
Yeah.
My,
my ex girlfriend,
she could speak and she would tell me like all the time,
like that person just said I had nice tits and while we were walking by him,
but she learned after a while she wouldn't tell me until like minutes later
cause I kept on getting pissed.
I'd be like,
what the fuck?
You know,
dude tried to get all aggro.
No,
I just become an asshole.
Like I'm going to do so let me Susan.
Yeah,
they just,
they,
it's almost like they're doing it on the Internet.
Yeah.
You know,
they do it anonymously.
They think they're just getting away with it and it's not even really,
it was actually the opposite of doing on the Internet because it's only for
them,
you know,
it doesn't even reach you.
It's like them saying something conti about you but you can't even read it.
Yeah.
You see my George Washington put pictured
the George Washington with a terminator gun.
Hey Logan,
what does that about?
Uh,
this,
this artists on Etsy just makes all these like,
like presidents,
like,
like in like crazy situations like riding horses and Unicorns and tigers and
stuff.
It's fascinating that when you go back to the constitution and when you go back
to these guys that were originally starting off this country and they kind of
saw the shit common,
it's really amazing when you really look at like the obvious patterns of
corruption that people in power seem to follow over and over and over again.
Those guys all saw it coming.
They all,
they all saw it coming.
They had,
you know,
they have provisions,
they had it set up.
So you're supposed to protect people from that as much as possible.
Not supposed to use the military to control civil unrest.
You don't supposed to be used the army on it's citizens.
All
that was changed by Nda.
That's the,
another thing that a lot of people don't know that was,
you're allowed to use the military.
Now.
The military can come in the army against US citizens.
That's,
that's crazy.
The whole country can be declared a battlefield.
Yeah.
And,
and that only,
you only know what I mean.
If they're going to all of these lengths to,
to create the ability to do that.
What,
what's in store when it comes to descent?
You know,
I mean,
did you see the photos out of Anaheim?
Yes.
Uh,
of all the police,
Johnson.
Yeah.
I was there a camouflage.
You see the Walmart one the other day?
They had like the sound canyons and everything like that at a Walmart protest.
Some of those a protests.
Yeah,
I'll find it.
I know.
The,
um,
the Anaheim thing was weird because there was a media blackout about it.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
you know,
the,
it was,
it was really ugly.
The watching people wearing full military gear with Cammo desert cammo walking
through the streets.
It's really unsettling because first of all,
why?
Why are they wearing fucking Cammo?
You know,
that's a,
what are you hiding?
Are you pretending we're in Iraq?
Are you reminding me that these people are,
are trained killers that go to Iraq and now I'm the enemy?
Is that what this is supposed to be?
The am I supposed to feel unpatriotic for not giving in to what's going on here?
A cop shot a kid in the back and people were freaking out.
That's everybody should be freaking out.
Obviously some horrible thing happened.
Everybody should be freaking out,
including these people that are holding these guns,
including these people wearing Camo with body armor.
You should be freaking out too,
because this is all America.
This is all part of your community and someone who was in a position of power
made a horrible mistake and these people want justice and you know what?
They should get it.
There's are,
they should,
they should be able to feel safe.
There's a terrible gap between the way people are in power,
whether it's police officers,
whether it's a mill,
anybody that is in a position of power and the people that gets suppressed with
those people,
that that gap is a a really scary thing and what a cop is,
who was in a position of power shoots a kid and then they see no repercussions.
They see a completely different reaction than if the kid had shot the cop.
Everybody has a right to freak out because we are supposed to be equal in this
country and someone who's in a position of power clearly crossed all the legal
lines.
They clearly fucked up.
They clearly violated the relationship between the person in power and the
person they're supposed to be protecting and to see people reacting.
That's the way they chose to react by sending in the military.
Whoa,
that's,
that's not how you're supposed to do it.
You're supposed to do it by sitting down with the community and figuring out
what we can do to make sure this never happens again,
and to make sure that the person who did this never has the opportunity to do
this again.
Whether it's put them in jail,
whether it's taken him out of office,
you know,
fire them instantly and put them in jail,
whatever it is,
whatever,
you know,
the,
the courts deem the correct action.
But you have to have justice.
Do you have to have justice for everybody?
It can't just be for people who can afford it.
It can't just be for people in power.
It just be,
it's,
we're in a weird place now.
It's a weird place.
Is this,
what is this?
This is it.
The Walmart photos,
which I got a check out these,
uh,
like that.
That's one of those sound o and l Rad device.
Yeah.
Now what happened?
And they have look at that.
That's just what Heather just mean.
It looks like something out of judge Dredd.
I,
I just,
you know what that is?
That's intimidation.
See that.
See those people,
they are,
they're not armed.
They're not.
Look at that old older man.
It's,
it's an intimidation tactic.
I saw that when I was covering the protests in Anaheim.
It's a way to try to make people scared.
Did just so it's not that they're,
they're anticipating that they're going to need all that armor.
They're only doing that because they want everybody to freak out that the storm
trooper,
and you're starting to see that,
uh,
we saw it at the Republican National Convention.
You're starting to see that all over the country.
And that's why,
uh,
where he's music as a journalist.
Um,
Anaheim was,
I mean,
that guy,
man,
we'll Diaz was shot in broad day light.
So people were obviously upset.
And I remember being there and we were in the middle of the road at a march and
I looked over my shoulder and I saw the trucks coming down the street with guys,
with police officers dressed in Camo.
And I had to,
I,
it's almost like everything just came to a stop.
Even the protesters,
everyone could not believe what they were seeing,
that these officers were dressed like that for unarmed children and women and
men who were protesting.
And,
uh,
you know,
it's,
uh,
I feel a systematic,
crushing of dissent or protests by,
by police departments across the country.
Was there any danger what it was there?
Any looting or any rioting?
We,
what was going on that they would feel the need to bring in and essentially,
you know,
tanks and military.
What did,
what is that?
They were trying to head to Disney land.
So the protesters are upset.
They feel like it was influenced somehow by Disneyland because they were going
to march and they felt that the you,
you see them.
Yeah.
There they are on horseback.
Oh,
I remember I took a shot of that lady tail.
Um,
and so they,
they literally made it impossible for the protesters to march.
Look,
that's,
that's what I saw when I was walking down the street shooting photographs and I
couldn't believe it.
Horses dudes on.
Um,
yeah.
And,
and look,
they're carrying Boykins in their hands.
Those are wooden Japanese swords to hit people with Si.
See that officer there.
Um,
not only that,
they were firing beanbag rounds and,
and tear gas and the horses were bog goggles on and right there that's at the
intersection.
And they wanted to go down that intersection and turn and head to Disneyland to
protest because they felt soldiers with fucking machine guns.
If you,
I have another video look up Tim pool and Amber Lyon shot at by Anaheim police
because we were trying to cover this Joe and um,
and the police we had noticed,
kept setting up walls to keep us behind the police officers as we were covering
it so we wouldn't be there with the people,
uh,
to see how they were being treated.
Also to see how they were being shot with these nonlethal Wa rounds.
And at one point I was actually fired on by the Anaheim police department with
Leslie's lethal rounds,
but they,
I was clearly standing in a busy street and they knew,
here we are.
I can see something,
I can see Kara.
So we're in a busy street and there I am right there.
And the guy yells,
fucking pigs and then listen,
now
see the u haul,
right.
Then I stopped and I was literally sitting there and I hit him between two u
hauls as,
as rounds kept going past,
he was able to smart enough to be able to scale a wall.
But Watch,
he gets fired on again.
By the way,
those bullets and nonlethal they can take your eye out easily.
Not only that,
if they hit you in the ribs,
um,
and your,
your ribs go into your heart,
it can kill you if it hits you in the neck.
Um,
and,
and in the header can crack your skull.
I've seen it happen overseas.
Jesus Christ.
And this isn't just a neighborhood of an Anaheim.
People were,
were,
uh,
so they fired on you.
Like you guys are like this is a war.
Yeah.
And I was hiding between the two u hauls and I was yelling for Tim because I
didn't know he had gotten away and I thought he had been hit.
And so
yelling for him to see if he was okay and then,
um,
and look,
he's running now cause they're just shooting down the streets.
I mean,
these poor people living in this neighborhood.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
And,
and so at this point I come out and this is just the cops doing this.
Yeah,
this is the police.
So who are we really scared of here?
The protesters or the police cause of protesters weren't shooting at me.
And,
and I,
and I clearly have blond hair and a bright green shirt on and,
and was shooting photos of a dumpster that had been set on fire.
And I,
and finally,
when,
uh,
after a couple of minutes I ran out and I screaming press and the,
and they quit firing.
And one of the officers looked at me and said,
I was really worried about you.
And then,
and then he also said,
don't you know how to cover a riot?
And then he pointed back at a photographer who was behind the police line with
them following the police,
instead of actually hanging out with the protesters like we're supposed to do as
journalists.
We're,
we're,
we're out there to be a watchdog on authority and protect the public.
And in other words,
that's,
that's what I believe they were doing is trying to keep me from being with the
protesters to film their injuries as civilians and bystanders or getting hit by
these,
these less,
less lethal rounds.
Um,
and,
and that that's pretty scary because they're trying to oppress not only these,
these voices of dissent but journalism and journalists.
How was that possible
that are the system of government that we have that the people that are in power
are slowly tightening things down on us in the same age as the,
the information we're getting from the,
the Internet now the,
the same age of instant information,
instant about anything,
answers,
any question.
The,
the distribution of information through social,
through podcasts and Twitter and Facebook,
it's never been greater.
The the access to information,
it's like so instant and so,
so she,
but yet at the same time you have these crazy crackdowns as crazy police state.
It's almost like we're putting,
turning the light on a vampire and it's shrieking and reacting and showing us
it's true self like in this,
these days gone by when we didn't have the access to information,
when we didn't know what was going on during the Gulf of Tonkin and we didn't
know what was going on during who knows how many different United States
ventures overseas we w w when we didn't know we,
we had a different impression of ourselves.
We have a different impression of the whole system of government that we
operated under.
We had a,
is it that or is it things are getting worse?
Is it that or we really do have crooks in,
in office and they are acting differently than Jimmy Carter would have or Bill
Clinton would have.
I mean,
is that what's going on?
I think that it's a little bit of both.
I think that it's surprising law enforcement that,
oh my gosh,
wait a minute.
I can't just shoot it.
Someone now the video is going to go on youtube and people will know forever
that I did this.
Uh,
so,
so thank goodness for social media.
It's making a lot of this stuff,
this video,
this,
these cops shooting at you.
Um,
people picked it up,
our t picked it up,
people criticize our t,
but our tea at least has covering what's happening in this country.
Um,
and a couple other people,
um,
because it's,
uh,
they say,
you know,
it's state sponsored and they're not accurately portraying what's happening in
Russia.
Um,
but regardless though they are accurately covering what's happening here in the
U S and,
um,
and,
and that should have been,
if you're really looking at the situation with journalism and in the u s and the
survival,
and what's an important story that should have been on all of the mainstream
media outlets.
I mean,
we were,
we were just,
we were shot at,
well,
not just that,
those cops should go to jail.
What the fuck is that?
Someone yells out pigs.
So you start shooting him,
really shooting them with rubber bullets.
That's an asshole that has rubber bullets.
That's all it is.
That there's no,
this guy getting shot right here.
Yeah.
Oh Gosh.
Hello.
Drop your car right now.
He's loading a shotgun with um,
those are,
um,
beanbag rounds.
It's essentially a legend who maintained your line and look at them.
They're,
uh,
the majority of the,
so the community there is more than 50,
3% Hispanic.
The police forces about 24%.
This is so hard to talk about.
I get tongue tied.
I get back.
I don't know what to say.
It just,
it doesn't,
it seems it's like a horrible scene in a movie.
It doesn't seem real.
You know,
when you see this weird tightening down,
this weird police state,
this in impending police state that just keeps getting bigger and bigger and
worse and worse,
fucking flaming dumpsters.
I mean,
this is a God damn video game.
Yeah.
And these guys were just,
they were walking down in rows.
The police just walking through these neighborhoods and you'd see people
appearing out their gates fare.
They're looking just horrified as walls of police officers.
Um,
uh,
we'd just come through their neighborhoods and just start firing and going
through a dark alleyways and firing.
There are many times I had to scream,
press,
see,
look at that.
Right now they're just walking through these neighborhoods with their guns
pointed.
And these are elderly people and right.
There's those are beanbag rounds.
And then the red things are pepper balls and what the pepper balls do.
It's like a paintball but filled with,
with pepper spray and it comes out,
you know,
it makes it hard to breathe the beanbag rounds.
Those are what worry me because those have a led pellet wrapped around,
uh,
a pillow wrapped around a led pellet and they can still tear open your skin.
And like we were talking about earlier,
if they hit you in the chest and your ribs were to break and Pierce your heart,
you could die as well as it could crack your skull.
It's killed people if it hits you in the neck.
And that's why it's terrifying to be shot at like that.
And you saw those people just standing in the street
doing it like it's nothing just like it's nothing and shoot at that guy when
he's just standing up holding his hands.
That's in fucking insane.
That's insane.
Yeah.
A lot of pedestrians were,
um,
were hit or had to dodge bullets because they,
they just came out to see what was happening.
They saw a dumpster on fire instead of what's going on.
And they would stand on the street corners and just look to see what was going
on.
They weren't even involved in a protest and they were fired on,
is this how it's always been?
It doesn't seem like it.
It doesn't seem like that would have happened just a decade ago.
Don't let me,
doesn't it was,
was,
was this how it was?
I mean,
obviously they had a clamp down during the la riots,
but it seems like the La riots was a far more violent protest and was,
it was far crazier and it was a huge racial divide.
But even then,
I don't remember seeing this.
I don't remember seeing people just walking down streets just firing
indiscriminately into alleys and shooting it.
Reporters shooting at people that call them pigs.
I mean,
someone calls you a pig,
you're allowed to shoot at him.
It was,
I mean,
really,
that's crazy.
Yeah.
And,
and I think that,
um,
you know,
that has been a journalistically a lot of us have been trying to analyze whether
things have gotten worse or they haven't.
And um,
I've just noticed myself,
I've been covering the protest for a year.
I've noticed things getting worse as far as the garb that police are wearing.
The,
the video game,
like intimidation tactics.
Why when they wear these ridiculous uniforms to a,
a couple of old people in front of Walmart,
you saw that this is systematically dangerous for this country.
Because what it does is it instills fear and,
and people and it makes people scared sometimes to get out and protests.
Not only that,
it agitates people look at Anaheim,
they were fine.
They just had come out to get upset about Manuel Diaz and then the police show
up and start firing on them.
I don't know if you saw the video of the police dog getting loose on the crowd.
I did,
yeah.
I mean that's another hard one.
Watch
anywhere.
Just cop said that it slipped and it lost the leash.
Whoops.
Yeah,
sorry.
I'll let the monster go
on.
Women and children and they were walking with their guns and just firing on
people in broad daylight?
No.
What did the protesters do that started the,
I mean there was ed.
Was there any violence at all that started this escalation?
I,
I think,
uh,
at first it started with the police dog getting loose on the crowd.
Um,
are you talking about just Anaheim?
Yeah.
Like what did,
what did Anaheim did,
what did the protesters do that started this escalation?
Well,
what happened was first the police dog got released on the crowd and then there
were firing on women and children.
And so that created a lot of anger.
Then they went to city hall to complain and then the protesters didn't leave the
front of City Hall.
So that night,
um,
a,
I think a couple rocks had been thrown or,
um,
I know a bottle at one point came right past my head and hit the ground.
So I don't know,
but I didn't see who threw it.
Um,
but it did come from the crowd of,
of protest or so.
So that could have been what?
Agitated the situation.
Um,
but at the same time,
she's fairly minimal.
For what the way the escalation that you see in that video?
Yeah.
And and right after a bottle or a rocks were thrown,
I mean the,
uh,
wall of officer's w when I say a wall,
a wall of officer's just started Bam,
Bam,
Bam into the,
into the crowd.
And there were women and children.
And
is this video quick close up?
Yeah.
It's so crazy.
I mean,
I know that Obama can't have his finger on every trigger.
He can't be the one that's calling for all of this.
But it just,
it's so shocking for me after the,
the idea that every,
everybody kind of thought when this guy got into office that at least socially
this was a change for the better.
This was a guy who was obviously really intelligent,
really like edge,
highly educated,
thoughtful,
a great speaker,
young and vibrant,
and this sort of represented hope.
A black guy.
He's the president.
It just represented like this new breath of fresh air.
Like finally we got this guy in the office.
This is fucking president in my whole life.
I've been waiting for this guy to be in the office and then this shit happens.
It's like,
it's,
it's crazy.
It's,
it's the best evidence ever that the president doesn't really get to ever really
be the president that the president is just a puppet.
And that's when I came to that realization because I,
I,
um,
when I saw that,
that everyone,
everyone had called for change.
And,
and then when I saw not only that,
but the historically speaking,
uh,
the Democratic Party has been more favorable toward journalism and journalists.
Um,
and,
um,
and to see the way he's attacking systematically journalism with Nda and with
the subpoenas,
um,
and,
and how things just really haven't changed.
The only thing that's changed as we've had now,
uh,
our,
our first amendment rights taken away from us at an alarming rate.
And it kind of makes you think you really have to,
you really have to stop and think you are not being extremist in your views and
you're not out there to really logically put things together,
put the pieces of this puzzle together and realize that we don't have control of
this country anymore.
It's,
it is,
uh,
nicely dressed dictatorship.
That's what it's like.
It's a,
it's got a cute costume on,
let's got this costume on it.
But if you look at the rules,
the rules are essentially a dictatorship with MDA specially that's just once you
become,
Julian Assange is essentially just did what a journalist is supposed to do.
I know there's a lot of people that are confused about what he did.
There's a lot of people,
there's a lot of misinformation about his releasing of names of people that were
undercover.
That's not true at all.
If you,
if you look at what he actually did,
what he actually did was released some horrific facts,
and that's supposed to be what journalism is about.
Journalism is supposed to be holding people accountable so that we don't have to
have this distorted perception of what we're doing overseas.
So we actually can see the horrific nature of of these crimes.
And they're,
they're fucking more crimes.
They're,
they're horrible things.
And it's a daily day to day thing and all of a sudden it was thrust into the
public eye,
but it wasn't by the New York Times and it wasn't by the Washington Post.
It wasn't by the Boston Globe.
It was by this one freaky dude with white hair,
you know,
and so it was really easy to call this guy in enemy.
It's really easy.
And that's what they've gotten him labeled.
Now he's an enemy of the state.
They have him labeled as an enemy of the state.
But you look at his actual actions,
there were really has been nothing horrible.
Even if he was a United States citizen,
there's nothing he did.
He what he did,
if he was a United States citizen would essentially be patriotic.
What he did was expose the bad elements of our government so that the good
elements could clean up the mess.
Because when you find a cop that's doing something illegal,
you find a cop.
It's selling drugs.
You don't,
it's not,
you're not supposed to bring that up and expose that and then you go to jail for
being an enemy of the state.
No,
it's supposed to be.
You have exposed a corrupt part of our system.
Thank you very much for doing that.
We got 'em now we arrest them like on CSI or on some fucking movie.
They would arrest him and throw him in jail,
but in the case of the u s most in the case of the US military were completely
beyond that.
We're completely beyond any accountability.
They're completely beyond any,
any exposure of any sensitive information that they don't leak themselves is
thought to be treasonous.
It's thought to be a crime against the state and that's a sickness.
That's a real sickness.
You are.
There is a bunch of crazy fox in power that are treating us the same way at king
treats his,
his,
his disciples.
It's really the same thing.
If you can't release clear video that show something wrong that has not been
addressed and that people did not know about and something that was going to
make people reconsider the way they think about the military.
We consider the way they think about what it is to have your own children over
there as as soldiers doing these things like what are we really doing?
If you look at that collateral murder video,
that's a disturbing fucking video and that's a good video for everyone to see
because it lets people know the truth and let's people know this really happened
and your government did not want you to know about it and they tried very hard
to keep this information from you.
Here's a bunch of other shit that really happened.
I mean the,
with each passing thing that they release,
it becomes more and more obvious how corrupt this entire system is from a
lobbyist and special interest groups to be being beholden to corporations to get
into control,
to controlling natural resources and different countries.
It's a giant money grab.
I mean that's all it is.
It's a,
and anybody that steps in and tries to fuck the money grab up is a terrorist.
Exactly.
And that's what's so terrifying about Nda and that's what has journalists
concerned and,
and whistleblowers concerned.
And,
and I,
and I love Joe,
that you guys talk about whistleblowers and hold them in the light.
They should be,
uh,
the light that should be shown on them.
And that's it.
They're heroes.
We need them.
We need them to point out the broken parts of the machine so that we can fix
those parts one by one and keep the machine going.
Yes,
the machine needs to be going.
It's not like the Ma,
we want to overthrow the government.
It's not,
we just don't want it to be corrupt and thought,
that's amazing that that is,
that that is controversial in 2012 with the amount of access to information that
we have,
we,
we should have evolved much further as a civilization.
If we had more whistle blowers,
we would,
because they'd be able to do what I've done with CNN.
And I said that this isn't right.
Look what they're doing with it.
As a viewer,
you should know when you're watching this at state sponsored.
It's just a little thing that will help enlighten some people.
We need that information.
It's power and ma overhaul.
Overwhelmingly Americans are amazing positive people who,
who are able to make a difference and would be horrified if they knew of some of
the things that are happening in the military and in these corruptions.
And that's why they're going to such great lengths to keep people from coming
forward.
I remember.
Why do you hate America?
Yeah.
I know.
Well that scares me too.
Yeah.
Do you ever hear that kind of talk to speak to,
do you get that?
Um,
I,
I do and I,
and I also get the,
uh,
oh Geez,
you guys are coming knocking on the door.
I don't have the government.
Oh,
this didn't we all get arrested on,
on video?
That'd be hopefully the cops or UFC fans tickets if you don't shoot us.
I love it.
We laugh about that.
But um,
do you worry?
I do worry and I've had,
I've actually had hundreds at this point of emails.
Mostly from Alex is folks worried about my safety and they just want to fuck
you.
Yeah.
I'll come to your personal battle.
I'm worried about your safety.
Lucky I have body armor specifically for your size.
Yeah.
In my compound there's plenty of food.
We could live on the ground for six months.
That's all it takes for the radiation to die down.
Yeah.
I have had a lot of a body guard offers.
So maybe that's why I'm getting that.
But uh,
I know there is a feeling and the journalist community now that
especially with Nda,
that we are scared that one day there's going to be a knock on the door
and get arrested.
Yeah.
And you gonna get taken away and you can get detained and you can get detained
indefinitely.
And that's a,
that's the law now.
You don't have to,
you don't,
you don't have the rights that you had just a year ago.
And for people,
people need to wrap their head around that.
Like it's not innocent until proven guilty.
It's,
there's none of that.
It doesn't exist anymore.
Like that's gone away.
And that's not what we think of when we think of this country.
We think of the constitution.
We think of all the rights that were endowed with we,
we,
we don't understand that that's gone.
Yeah.
And then people don't,
people like you center.
Just why are you talking about NDA?
Well,
it,
it's so terrifying because this is now,
I mean,
come on,
let's get to it.
The,
the black and white of it.
What,
what's a terrorist anymore?
Nelson Mandela was called a terrorist.
Martin Luther King.
I mean,
now you can use terrorist to pretty much to try to take out any of your enemies
or anyone who is,
is maybe an investigative report or a radio show host who against what the
government's doing.
And,
and that is so scary for so many of us.
I love it when they became insurgents and what's hers is going on now to become
an insurgent.
You know,
you know,
you're not the enemy anymore.
They're insurgents.
They're doing battle with insurgents.
Like surgeon,
I don't even know.
I'm a turtle.
It's don't even know what the hell it is.
But it became sort of a,
a word that was forced into the vernacular.
It's like that all,
I'd never used that word insurgent my whole life.
I went 39 plus years by using the word and surgeon,
and then all of a sudden it's just be tossed around in the news every day.
And I'm like,
where the fuck network come from?
Never even heard of it before.
It's just a cute way of saying,
you know,
some dudes we're going to shoot,
some people that are angry at us,
the enemy,
whatever it is.
Um,
what do you,
what else did you see that you thought was being censored or downplayed?
How mean how much of Wiki leaks was,
uh,
how much of that was,
was,
you know,
censored over there?
Yeah,
I mean,
I don't even know how much I can,
it's just,
I feel like I could talk about all of this forever,
but this is really one of the first times I'm,
I'm talking about the Wiki leaks issue.
Um,
but that was,
that was another hands off kind of red tape story as well.
And,
um,
and that,
that was,
uh,
it was difficult to get coverage of that,
especially with any type of leaks.
This is what's happening now.
If someone comes forward with a leak to the mainstream media now because of
Obama's subpoenas,
they have to analyze the legal aspect and whether they're willing to pay the
money if it's potentially subpoenaed.
And so that makes stories more expensive.
Um,
when it comes to leaks.
Also,
a story that I saw,
uh,
that was very difficult to cover was ICU have a mask over their anonymous.
Um,
that became really difficult to cover because pretty much at this point,
the FBI came out last year in,
um,
last winter and talked about how they feel a cyber terrorism is as one of the
biggest to the country.
And,
and in that speech,
Robert Mueller also mentioned,
uh,
he threw an aline about script kitties and people working on computers and they
are in their parents basements,
which pretty much meant he was referring to anonymous.
So,
so journalistically that became,
if you cover anonymous,
you have a chance of getting subpoenaed because the federal government is
against a nonce.
And so it became very difficult to cover that story as well.
And um,
and became a more of an analysis on whether we're able to spend the legal money
than whether the story is journalistically important.
I think the anonymous story is,
is very important because we can't allow the federal government to come out and
just call people terrorists or stay cyber terrorists or try to instill fear.
We need to know there's a mask,
the guy Fawkes mask.
Uh,
we need to know,
we as journalists,
we need to be able to talk to these people to see what they're really all about.
We all know now we can't trust our government to tell us who our enemies should
be.
We need to know as journalist,
we need to be able to go and talk to people even down to al Qaeda.
We need to be able to get in and talk to these indigenous
sure.
What could possibly be the justification and on the side of the government
could,
could they be like,
we have to do this to protect people?
Could they be thinking that we have to clamp down on all these rights in order
to ensure the safety of the United States?
I mean,
what,
what the fuck?
Or they,
or they just look were corrupt,
were just corrupt.
This is how we do it.
We're just assholes,
you know,
or,
or it really lets you know who's the agenda there they're on.
Like if you look at the situation with the FBI going after anonymous and
spending those kinds of resources on,
on anonymous,
wait a minute,
why aren't you going after the bankers here?
Why are you spending these resources doing these elaborate missions to,
to try to crush hackers who,
the majority of them are actually on human rights missions and aren't even
hackers.
They're just disseminating information on the internet.
And that's when I knew that that was another thing because they'd hit some
corporations and so it's like,
okay,
so they're going after anonymous because the corporations are controlling our,
our law enforcement decisions.
I mean that was the black and white of this situation.
Why aren't they going after bankers?
Why are they going after anonymous?
And that's why it's important for us as journalists to be able to get in and,
and,
and talk to these individuals.
I wonder how they justify it at the highest level.
I really would love to see the meetings when,
when they get together and draft something like the National Defense
Authorization Act.
I would love to see what the,
the,
the conversation is like when you like what do you want to put in there?
Oh,
we were fucking lock them up,
but for whatever,
for whatever.
Anything.
If you want to just put for being an enemy of the state.
Yeah.
Let me say that's good.
That's good enemy of the state,
which is such a vague,
you know,
terminology that you can use it for journalists,
a guy like Julian Assange because Julian Assange with wikileaks and not with the
New York Times of Julia and the was with the New York Times,
The New York Times released all those wikileaks documents.
It would have been a very different story.
But because he's in this wiki leaks,
what the fuck is a Wiki leak?
It's connected to Wikipedia,
which is sort
of silly as it is,
not completely reliable,
you know?
So it's sort of this we easy Lee,
it's dismissed.
It's not the New York Times.
New York Times has been around.
This is a new thing because it's a new thing.
We can say,
it doesn't count.
Like you can't have new journalism doesn't,
doesn't exist.
The only the stuff that already is here,
because we've got that shit under wraps.
So because it wasn't with the New York Times,
then all of a sudden this guy can be labeled an enemy of the state.
I mean,
could you imagine?
it would be a very different reaction at the New York Times printed that and the
government went after the New York Times and called the New York Times,
the enemy of the state.
Then people would have to go,
whoa,
like what's going on here?
But because it's Wiki leaks,
they should have,
everybody should have every journalism,
uh,
every,
but every person that cares about true principles,
every journalist should have.
Stan stood up and I mean it should have been the front page of every newspaper.
It should have been like,
this can't happen.
This is why it can't happen.
This is why we need people to watch after the government we need,
we need people to make sure that all,
you can't just trust the government to look out for the good of the people.
You need people watching them,
and that's what journalism has always been about.
It seems like that's what that guy's doing.
It seems.
It doesn't seem like he's doing anything different,
but yet he's in hiding in a fucking embassy in London now and they're circling
in the house trying to figure out how to get them out.
I mean it's,
it's nuts.
It's really weird because essentially they're saying,
I mean they're talking about going in,
they've talked about going in several times,
but essentially they're saying that the rules are bullshit.
Like we've,
we've tenders rules,
but there really are no,
no rules.
You're,
you're,
what is it a consulate and embassy look through?
It's a fucking house.
It's right there.
And the guy we wants in there,
we're going to go and get them.
And that's really what's happening right now.
And he's just there,
just waiting him out.
He's sitting there for months waiting him out
and they've succeeded in.
And their main goal in all of this was to distract.
It's a PR tactic.
Let's distract,
distract,
and they've succeeded.
They've distracted from the actual leak.
And now it's become more about Julianne and him having to hide in the embassy
and,
and these,
um,
you know,
accusations out of Sweden and it hasn't become about what we really should be
looking into and that was the leak and how we can,
can fix that in the future.
So,
so that,
uh,
horrific situations of civilians getting shot by US troops don't,
don't happen again,
but,
but we're not focusing on that now because we're too busy focusing on where's
Julian now?
And,
and that's what they want.
And they've succeeded.
The fact that they're putting so much attention,
emphasis and focus on this one guy and that they're doing it because he had
surprise sex with someone really doesn't mean it's not even,
they're not even calling it rape.
I mean it's not,
he's not a murderer,
he's not an armed robber.
He's someone who had consensual sex with someone and then then there's some like
weirdness that went on.
I don't know what it was,
but whatever it was,
even if he was guilty of it,
it doesn't seem like it's nearly enough to warrant this kind of attention.
I mean,
this is fucking crazy.
If we had to go over every guy who did something creepy sexually and we had a,
you know,
send a fucking army after them.
I mean that's the,
that's never happening.
That's not,
that's not going to happen.
This is,
it's bullshit and it,
but it's the most obvious bullshit.
It's like,
it's so thinly veiled.
It's insulting and how ridiculous it is.
If you look at them like the Julian Assan standing on those little balcony and
he can't leave the embassy and they go,
why is he there for?
And then you find the actual thing that they're going after and be like,
what?
Wait a minute.
What?
That's crazy.
Like this is what they're using.
There's some weird sex thing that he did in Norway or Sweden or whatever the
fuck.
Where was it?
Oh,
sweet.
Sweden.
Uh,
and you know,
uh,
they're also trying to send a message with that to journalists like myself and
others is,
look,
what's going to happen to you if you,
if you leak the leaks and,
and,
and that's what they're doing to it.
It's a systematic way to try to prevent people from leaking information about
corruption.
But those leaks are vital to the survival of whatever ounce of democracy we have
left in this country.
And we need leaders.
We need whistleblowers.
They're heroic.
They're fantastic.
If something is happening in your corporation that you know is,
is violating the public good,
you should leak that information too.
Because if no one knows what's happening,
we can't,
we can't fix it.
A true patriot is supposed to be someone who protects against enemies,
both domestic and foreign.
That's supposed to be the idea is that it's not that we can't have foreign
people that we love and that our allies,
and it's not that we can't have domestic people who are truly our enemies.
I mean,
and anybody who's trying to turn this country into what it's becoming.
When you see these fucking soldiers walking down streets,
when you,
you read the language and the NDA and you go,
Whoa,
I can sign this.
Like how did this get through?
Oh,
that's the enemy.
There's,
there's an and one of the whether or not that enemy,
I don't know.
I don't know if it's on the political side.
I don't know if it's corruption.
I don't know if it's incompetence.
I mean they say that no one ever reads any of those fucking bills anyway.
That they're too long.
They say that if the Congress really read everything that they sign,
it would be in physically impossible.
Like they would have,
like if you talk to them about what's in things,
like there's a lot of them that,
that don't,
they,
they can't read it.
They can,
you know,
that's where journalists failed in journalism failed because we should have had
a,
a tremendous amount of reports on NDA and really a lot of more people raising
hell about it.
Um,
but it's been censored by the mainstream media and,
and so,
uh,
Congress reacts to pressure.
If the public doesn't pressure Congress not to sign the NDA,
then then they're going to sign it.
And,
and,
and that's what happened.
God,
it's so weird.
It's a,
it's just you,
you,
you look towards the future.
And I have young children,
I have a two year old and a four year old and I look at what their life is going
to be 10 years from now,
20 years from now.
And if,
if things keep clamping down the way they are,
it's,
it's a fucking horrific mess.
And it seems to be,
if you look at the amount of money we're spending overseas,
and if you look at the incredible military budget,
I mean,
it's just astounding how much money,
it's not a lack of resources that we have.
It's just how those resources are being allocated.
Those resources have been allocated.
And these really weird ways.
Is it because we just need,
in order to keep our lifestyle,
we need to control these,
these natural resources,
whether it's in Iran or whether it's in whatever it is that we need to do in
other car.
Is that really what's going on?
Is it to protect our lifestyle here?
I don't know.
I don't know what it is,
but I definitely know this is not the right way to do it.
There's gotta be a better way for the whole system to be run unquestionably.
And it seems like it's almost like there's like,
like they're conceding that it's out of control.
So in conceding that it's out of control,
they're like,
look,
we've got to fucking take away their rights.
We got to make sure that we can take their computers.
We want to be able to just fucking take all their money out of the bank.
We can do that whenever we want.
We can just say,
you don't have any money money home anymore.
Now it's all ours.
We've gotta be able to figure out how to stop some Arab spring type shit from
happening here.
And this is how to stop it.
Stop it.
Well we make essentially doing whenever we want legal.
So all shit that should be completely illegal because they wrote some things
down and some asshole signed it that didn't read it.
Then what's horrific now becomes law.
Yeah.
And it's uh,
and I think it,
they want people want you to think it's out of control.
But this is very systematic.
That language in the NDA is very systematic.
The crackdown down on dissent in this country is very systematic.
And the crackdown on journalism who could expose the descent is systematic.
And the fact that this stuff has not airing on all these mainstream outlets that
are connected to all these corporations and governments is systematic.
So they may make it appear to be more chaotic than it is,
but,
but it really is a systematic crackdown on,
on dissent and,
and people who are criticizing the government,
the average person who works in hours a day,
who has a mortgage bills,
Carly's things to think about relationship troubles.
Do they even know what the fuck is going on?
Does,
what percentage of the population is waking up?
I,
I'd say it's,
it's small,
but it is,
is an army of people waking up.
Um,
I,
and I know that from after going on Alex Jones show and,
and the response I got after that,
uh,
I was really relieved.
I said,
okay,
I'm not shouting alone.
There are people out here that see what's happening.
But at the same time,
you know,
I'll,
I'll then go and talk with,
uh,
my family living in the Midwest and then they're not aware of what's happening
there.
They're busy watching a real housewives of orange county or you know,
or they'll say something like,
well,
they're over there fighting for our freedom.
Yeah.
Or just,
yeah,
the propaganda.
They'll just recite the propaganda that they've been fed.
That's one that hurts.
They're over there fighting for freedom.
That one fucking hurts.
That hurts.
My brain hurts.
It hurts when you see the caskets that they're not to photograph.
It hurts when you hear people that have lost friends,
loved ones eat,
run into people that have no legs.
They'd come back from Iraq and you're like,
for what?
For what?
What are they doing this for?
Really?
This is the only way to do it.
This is the best way to do it.
Where's that money going?
Billions and billions and billions of dollars a month.
I mean,
it's somewhere around six to $7 billion per month.
It's costing us.
It's insane.
When you think about if,
if that money could be turned on just just helping the United States,
just helping the poor community,
United States trying to figure out alternative fuel sources.
Trying to,
I mean just putting into,
it's like there's a stranglehold on the way things are run now and the,
the,
the money that's being extracted with the way things run now has such incredible
power over our lives.
It's really amazing how small groups,
relatively small groups of people.
If you stop and think about the actual amount of people that are involved in oil
corporations,
the amount of people that are involved in government and you compare it to the
whole world,
it's a very,
it's relatively small,
but that relatively small group of people has this insane effect on our day to
day lives and the future of humanity.
The future of literally the human race because if we are the biggest superpower
in the world,
if then that's what we are.
I mean there's never been anything like the United States.
Rome was never even fucking close to,
as crazy as we are.
We have military bases in over a hundred countries and there's a lot of people
that don't know that and this is all falling apart right before our eyes and
it's all crumbling right before and it's all going down like a crazy fucking
movie,
like some crazy apocalyptic movie.
It's going on right before our eyes.
And most people are just stuck in traffic.
They're just listening to some fucking Kanye West Song.
Can't wait to get home to watch the latest Kim Kardashians show.
And it's,
it's,
we are,
we are fucking strange.
It's been set up that way.
I mean,
the more ignorant people are,
the more you can get away with and look at our programming or television
programming.
It's,
I was talking with some producers other day who have been trying for years to
feed these networks,
intelligent programming and hardcore new shows and,
and chose to educate the public.
And instead they said a show about some people catching alligators in swamps was
approved.
So this has been a systematic over the years.
It is a great show,
but over the years it's been
this one here,
honey booboo.
Honeyboo Ville.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's been a systematic bigfoot hunter.
Okay.
I haven't watch that Sasquatch or finding big foot rather,
dude,
I'm not going off on these shows.
But we need,
we need some educational program.
We do,
we do.
Do
we,
we need a better system.
We needed,
need a better system,
not just of government,
but of life.
You know,
there's,
there's too many people in this world that are living these really horrible and
fulfilling lives.
And I don't think that's necessary.
I think there's too many people out there are in what feels to them an
unproductive,
unsatisfying cow cog in a wheel.
And all of that leads to this feeling of detachment from the events of our
world.
And we sort of allow the people that are in the positions of power to manipulate
these great masses of people.
I mean,
I've always said that the idea of a country's really kind of ridiculous at a
certain point,
if it's not ridiculous today,
it's ridiculous.
A hundred years from now.
The interconnectedness of human beings through technology is eventually going to
make the idea as a physical bow of boundaries and barriers where you can't go
over there because this dirt is controlled by these people.
But you can't go.
It's,
it's crazy.
It doesn't make any sense.
It's a,
eventually we're going to have to accept the idea of a world community.
And uh,
when,
when you think of the future and you think of what a world communicate community
would be like,
one thing's for sure is you're not going to be able to control all those people.
You're not going to,
they're going to have to,
it's people are going to have to
be served by,
by,
by the notions and,
and then the,
the beliefs that they have by,
by the ideas of community,
by the ideas of sharing the ideas of making.
And enhancing each other's lives.
The idea of,
of having a real community of human beings on this one planet instead of these
ridiculous little teams that were on,
whether it's fucking,
I hate Texas because I'm from Oklahoma,
or you know the United States,
England can go fuck themselves.
You know,
it's,
it's at a certain point in time we're going to,
we're going to connect to each other to the point where we realize we are really
just one giant community and if we're one giant community,
we can't get led by these one people that have more ones and zeros that want to
send giant metal killing machines.
The places we've never been,
because there's minerals there or because there's heroin there are,
because there's oil there because there's whatever the fuck it is [inaudible]
that's not gonna work anymore.
It's going to get to a point in time where that's not going to work.
And I think that's what this big clamoring for taking away rights is all about.
I think the writing on the wall is that the,
the Internet,
the Internet is changing the game.
It's changing humanity.
It's changing.
We,
I don't even think we even realize when,
when history looks back and they look at 1993,
94 whenever AOL started,
when they look at that to now,
and that is a Co Raisie change and the way people look at the world and just,
uh,
just just by access,
just access to each other,
just the ability to communicate with each other and find out.
There's other people that think like you find out there's other people that are
scared and confused and find his other countries that are taking over their
country.
They're taking it back and they're fighting against corruption.
And then,
you know,
the United States sees that and goes,
fuck this.
Start cutting cords.
You need to,
we need to be able to cut the internet.
We need to be able to shut off people's cell phones,
which is the latest apple.
Thanks a lot apple,
you fucking twats this ridiculous new thing that they've done when they've made
third party
option so that someone can turn off video cameras.
So all cops have to do that.
You can't take your battery out of your,
your iPhone.
You shut it,
like can you take your battery out?
I've always wondered that.
Well because it's supposed to be a larger battery.
If,
if you,
if you have a smaller battery,
if it's a removal,
if it's removed,
you have to have a housing in a place where it attaches and that that space is
all used up.
It really was about the march,
you know?
Um,
I,
I've just heard a lot of people with an insecurity community and train of
thought that,
that,
that right now are speculating,
why can't you take your battery out?
Well,
if you can't take your battery out,
then your gps can ever shut off and you can never,
I've,
I've had meetings with sources where I've had to throw them,
throw,
literally throw my iPhone out the window because they said they wouldn't talk to
me if I had an iPhone with me because there's no physical way to shut that phone
off.
It's,
so if anyone was monitoring me there,
there'd be no way.
If I had that phone in my presence
to keep it off.
It's really creepy that apple decided to include that.
The ability of a third party to shut off your video camera remotely and they
say,
well they will.
Well,
hey,
it's for concerts.
It's for guys like you,
Joe Rogan to do your comedy.
We don't want anybody recording.
That's not what it is.
[inaudible] there he does.
It's just stopping it.
Done.
Yeah.
Can't shut that little get to jump.
Brian loves it.
He loves it though.
He doesn't care.
He's like,
dude,
track me.
He makes love to that phone.
The phone is sexual to him.
I,
I've put 'em I've had to put postits over my,
my camera was on my phone and on my,
my laptop because when I see this sir,
the software that they have,
one of my friends who is a,
um,
is very savvy with knowing software and hacking and stuff,
has shown me programs where they can install it on your laptop and someone can
get in and they can control your camera so they can monitor you all the time.
Oh,
they can.
They can literally,
if you have a wifi connection,
they can go in and suck your information out of your laptop through the Wifi and
send it to another computer.
I mean,
all this stuff has been going on for years,
you know,
but I,
I didn't ever really hit me in my head and I said,
Gosh,
how many times have you had your laptop open when maybe you haven't been dressed
or other things,
you know,
so,
so now I just sticky sticky note over my laptop camera.
Yeah.
There's going to be completely grossed out by me that just maybe an off.
Nonstop.
I had a friend who was hired by corporations to hack into computers.
Um,
and he,
he said one,
one guy,
he acted his computer and he,
as he was recording the video off his computer camera,
he has all these videos of the guy picking his nose and doing other things,
uh,
that men tend to do in front of their,
their,
uh,
computers.
I'm not gonna
say what it is,
but you can assume videos of this guy beating off.
Yeah.
And,
and he actually brought this stuff to them as,
as part of is,
you know,
look what we have on you now.
Reveal the other end.
Wow.
So just so you know,
I would note what was the guy doing?
Like what was the worthy,
they so interested in him for?
Well,
we'll,
um,
it was,
it had to do with,
uh,
legal dispute with a firm.
But
something to know is that,
um,
you know,
as that anyone can access your computer at any time.
So to be the by class we just start shaving a little bit better or crazy.
How long has this technology been available?
Oh Gosh.
For years.
We're just,
anytime I figure,
anytime you find out about security technology or hacking technology has been
out for years,
sometimes decades since her mom finding out about the iPad or something.
That's so crazy and scary.
How many people do you think that they've done that and lawsuits and stuff like
that way and people just shut up about it because they have photos of them in
front of the computer?
Well,
I think that's what's so scary for people about this new NSA facility that
they're building.
The next thing I want to talk to you about,
bluffed,
Dale,
Utah.
If anyone wants to take a vacation for your civil rights,
that's where you should go.
You know,
tell everybody what that is.
Uh,
they're building a $2 billion domestic spying facility,
uh,
to,
to literally gather your information and you and your communications.
And most people say,
I always hear this over and over.
Well,
I'm not doing nothing wrong.
You know,
it doesn't matter if they're monitoring me.
It does matter because they're going to have a file on you for your entire life
of communication.
So say one day you do something that upset someone or say potentially a
potential employers hack into this database.
Okay.
So we want to find out what job's been up to over the years.
What we see based on his phone,
gps records that he tends to,
uh,
visit the casino too much.
So we don't want to hire him or we also see he's not religious or we see that,
you know,
he's been visiting an oncologist and he potentially has cancer,
so we don't want to,
we don't want to hire him for those health insurance reasons.
It is dangerous to allow the government to collect this kind of information on
its citizens.
Any of that information can be used down the road to blackmail you or keep you
from whistle blowing or as a journalist keep me from leaking a story or keep me
from even having the story in general because they know no way to track them on.
Do you think there's a way that they can ever stop everything from being public
information?
Because it seems to me that that's the trend.
It seems to privacy as slowly eroding and it doesn't seem to just be like one
group of people that has access.
It seems to be that there's going to be a point in time where everybody's going
to have access.
That technology is going to really,
it's going to bypass boundaries.
There's going to be no boundaries anymore.
Yeah.
We're almost getting to that point.
I know as an investigative reporter now,
we kind of,
a lot of us do things the old fashioned way.
We write things in notebooks now or just remember things because we can't,
I can't trust.
Oh,
I just dropped it.
Well now it's broken.
Um,
you're sending your tracking device.
I can't,
I can't trust my tracking device and I can't,
I can't trust that this hasn't been hacked into.
Or
do you have an android phone?
Because you can take the battery out.
Yeah,
I got rid of my iPhone specifically because of that,
because I went through six iPhone.
So that's one thing about it.
I went through six them because of those reasons.
I'd meet resources.
They said what you have to give her to that phone or um,
you know,
I had weird things.
Um,
so I,
yeah,
I don't,
I use the android system now
you are living a very non stereotypical 29 year old girl.
You're the,
you're liking a crazy movie.
I mean you're,
you're going to foreign countries and exposing things and removing cell phone
batteries and you're worried about being spied on,
covering your,
your,
your lens of your laptop.
Like what a weird world we live in.
What a weird world you live.
I know.
It is strange,
but that's,
I mean,
that's unfortunately,
that's the way it's become the reality.
It's become press journalists.
I even know journalists now who are contemplating leaving the United States and
go,
where,
where would you go?
I,
um,
I don't want to say want to keep it on the DL.
I'll tell you where I'm going.
Vancouver,
I,
Columbia,
Montreal,
Vancouver.
I've heard a lot of people I know they're called a source of mine in a
documentary I'm doing,
went to Canada.
You know,
a lot of people are people and that are planning where they're going to go.
If things get really bad,
would say Canada.
Toronto is amazing.
I love Canada.
I want to know what her secret spot is though.
She's not.
When the apocalypse hits,
you can't live with her.
Okay.
I don't need anybody guards.
I don't need,
no.
Uh,
I don't,
you know,
because I haven't,
I,
I've been thinking about it and I don't quite know.
I don't know.
I think for me it's almost too much to handle the thought of having to leave.
Um,
but for especially investigative journalists after the NDA pass,
that's a reality for all of us because we're going to piss people off and the
government.
So how are they going to come after us,
you know?
Um,
and,
and why did you pick Canada?
Why,
why was that your a,
your choice to Vancouver?
I love it up there.
Yeah,
go there all the time.
I do a lot of gigs in Canada.
I probably more popular in Canada than I am in America podcast.
The podcast is,
we're regularly in the top three in the iTunes,
in the comedy section in America.
But in Canada,
we're regularly number one at all the podcasts.
It's weird.
We have a crazy following in Canada.
We were just in Toronto.
I did Massey Hall in Toronto.
It was amazing.
It was crazy.
The fucking people are so nice.
There's 20% less douche bags up there.
The streets are way cleaner.
Everything is cleaner.
You see people like sweeping up and cleaning things.
They're just,
it's a better country.
It's,
they're not greedy assholes.
It's a completely different vibe.
The way you interact with people.
They don't have the same expectations as Americans do.
They don't have to.
Same,
the same point of view,
the same arrogance.
It's just a completely different vibe.
It's like someone took America and said,
you've got to,
we kind of remove some of the continents out of Americans and try,
let's try another civilization.
Let's try this.
This civilization that's not trying to overthrow the world.
They look the same.
They talk the,
I think I'm may escape
to North Korea.
I think that's the goal.
Go to.
Yeah.
That's good.
Why North Korea?
He's being silly.
Yeah,
that's,
there's another place.
If we really cared about human rights,
why aren't we in Mexico and North Korea?
Those are two places were really would be a cracking down and that's why
everyone needs to wake up because we're being led into a war with Iran.
I,
the writing's on the wall and it's a rock number two.
And instead of this time,
it's with Iran and Iran has some pretty tough allies in China and Russia,
and the American public is being fed bs and we're being led into Iran by the
same forces that led us into a rock.
And we need to wake up because it's,
it's,
it's going to happen soon.
And,
um,
and because we,
I mean,
all you have to do this is everyone's test.
Just turn on,
turn on the news,
the mainstream outlets,
CNN,
ABC,
CBS,
and Fox.
And you're going to see a constant demonization of Iran.
Not that they don't deserve it,
but based on everything happening here,
it's,
it's absurd.
What do they deserve it for?
Iran is doing anything bad.
What is it?
I think that,
you know,
a,
you have Aquaman,
Dennis,
John,
who doesn't have traditional western beliefs when it comes to homosexuality.
And also,
you know,
there is a beef they have with Israel.
That being said,
what he's been doing his for Toric,
he's been talking,
okay,
we don't just go and attack every single leader because of their,
they're insane rhetorical or we would be in every country including Mexico and
we're not.
And so,
so now you have to sit back and now that you can pull yourself away and first
step to recognizing what's happening is,
is to know that you're being fed propaganda.
And once you know that,
then you can stand back and you can analyze it intelligently and realize,
I mean,
look at the movies we have coming out,
Argo,
you think that is just coming out randomly,
Ben Affleck movie.
It's on a hostage situation that's going on in Iran.
I mean,
look at the timing of that.
Call me a conspiracy theorist.
I think this is systematic.
I think the public is systematically being fed fear of Iran.
How's that?
A Ben Affleck,
a CIA agent,
that work it is,
um,
it's,
it's that,
uh,
Americans were taken hostage and Iran and so it,
so,
and in the end,
maybe it's a heroic movie,
but in the end you also feel you have a fear of Iran.
It's going to put a fear of a Ron and everyone that goes and sees that,
um,
and,
uh,
that's a government plot
that they thought would be timely.
I mean,
maybe they,
maybe they thought that,
but regardless,
it's going to have an effect of,
of people that leave that theater are going to have more of a fear of Iran,
uh,
instilled in them at a time where the news is constantly demonizing Iran at a
time where we're about to potentially approved military action on the country.
Contrary to popular belief,
the,
the youth of Iran are very westernized in a lot of ways and they are not happy
with the way
that their country is portrayed.
They're not happy with,
with the,
the whole situation.
The situation of,
uh,
you know,
the way Iran treats its,
uh,
its foreign policy.
The,
the,
the young people there,
they're very Americanized.
There's a lot of that going on there.
Yeah.
You know,
you see them in the universities and you see the,
the different protests as they have over there.
It's really strange to think that you buy a shitty roll of the dice.
Could have been born there.
I could have been born there and we could be a part of this youth movement
that's trying to figure out why the fuck this country is so crazy.
Why?
Why are we trapped in this crazy empire with this wacky,
a minute jot guy out there speaking for us overseas,
making a mockery.
I mean he seems like a character chore,
Bad Guy.
He seems like we gave him the script and we're like,
listen dude,
first thing you want to do is say there's no gains and Iran.
He's like,
let's put posters.
Yeah,
I know it was preposterous,
but we want you to say it.
There's no gays in Iran.
I mean,
he's like a cartoonish bad guy.
Like the stuff he talks about it.
It's so stupid.
It's like,
how did you get to be the guy who talks when that's the shit that you're saying?
And,
and that's also the way the media,
I mean,
if you also look at the media has covered,
it's not that I'm defending him,
but the media tends to pick up on only cover those kinds of situations.
They don't cover the times when,
when he's speaking intelligently,
right.
Course.
And that's what's,
that's what's dangerous too is because we're not giving,
given the whole,
the whole story,
I'm trying to get an interview with him now.
I want to sit with him and a,
and I have a not,
well now that I mentioned it'll probably be stopped,
but I want to sit down with him and I want to get to the bottom of a lot of
these situations with,
with the whole wiping Israel off the map and in other situations,
because I can't trust that we've been fed the correct story on that,
uh,
through,
through the mainstream media.
I mean it,
the situation now is that even the other day Hockman dinners,
God was speaking in front of the UN and uh,
there's a video on the Internet now of,
um,
CNN cut him off and then the reporters started talking over him at a point when
he was talking about the fact that these countries,
all the countries could get together and get along peacefully.
He was talking about the potential for peace and said they went in and cut them
off and then,
oh yeah,
yeah,
listened to him and now he's trying to do this and,
and really demonizing him.
And in journalistically you,
you can't just do that.
And they didn't give him his fair share.
So maybe he's not quite as insane as,
as we've been led to believe.
There are many forces,
very powerful forces that want you to hate him and think he's freaking nuts so
that it justifies us going in and attacking him.
And when you start to realize that and look back at the Info you,
you realize you may be not being fed that the whole,
the whole picture here.
Knowing what you know and being in the position that you are,
you,
you know,
being a person who is behind the scenes at a major news outlet like CNN and you
get to see sort of the,
the strings that that hold the puppets up.
Is there a way to fix this?
Is there a way to the turn this ship around and sort of write America or is this
a constant protest until we fall
off the face of the earth and have a nuclear war?
Is it,
do we just scream and throw our hands up and pout and yell and scream until they
launched the missiles and that wipes us all out?
Or is it possible that with education,
with the distribution of information that's available today with,
you know,
people like us talking about it with people that are young,
like David Seaman growing up and becoming political leaders,
these is,
is it possible that we can write this thing that what we have is a group of
people that are in control of this country that really came from another era.
They came from an era of no disclosure.
They came from an era where,
you know,
Watergate happened every now and then,
but really it was because they wanted to catch them.
You know,
there's plenty of information that they have on everybody.
Let's just keep this thing going.
The along the way,
it's always gone along.
I mean,
is it,
is it possible that we can end this era and move into an era of transparency,
move into an era where people who are the leaders of this country are doing it
for the right reasons.
They're doing it because they truly are patriotic because they truly believe in
that.
The real ideals that we liked.
When we think of ourselves in the best light,
those ideals,
the ideals of being an American,
they can actually bring us more in line,
bring our actions more in line with that.
Is that possible?
It's only possible if people have access to information,
um,
and,
and in,
in a way that can compete with the main stream.
Um,
and,
and that doesn't quite exist yet.
There are a lot of strong forces outside your,
your show,
Alex Jones.
Um,
and,
and other,
uh,
entities that are,
that are actually bringing out,
talking about these things at the mainstream isn't talking about Nda.
I'm all these other issues affecting our civil liberties.
If those forces can't compete and get the message out just as loudly as the
mainstream,
then,
then I don't,
I don't know what direction this country is headed in,
but we need,
we need that information.
That information is power and it's,
it's definitely not getting to the masses,
um,
quite yet.
But if we get to a point where we can compete with,
with the mainstream and and really get,
get this information out,
then people will be enlightened and they'll,
and they'll know when things are happening and,
and can make a difference and actually look for solutions.
The real question is how long can they hold that off for?
Is it possible that they can fight that off with shit like Nda with all these
passing,
these sweeping bills about controlling the internet,
the Sopa type bills that they keep force feeding and pushing through it.
You know,
how long can they really stop that from happening because it seems like this is
a new era to me.
It seems like when I talked to people today,
like what?
I can mention this,
when I spoke with David Seaman,
when we,
we had him on the show,
it's like,
I didn't know anything when I was your age.
I was like,
he's 26 years old.
Dude,
when I was 26 I was retarded.
I didn't know anything about the way the world goes.
And you hear,
you are educating me on things.
You're,
you're completely immersed in the way this country is being run.
The corruption of lobbyists and corporations,
corporate influence on w w the way we do everything from grow our food to
extract oil.
Is this a new era?
I mean,
are,
are we dealing with this new wave of people who are informed,
who are growing into adulthood to push these old douche bags out of office?
I mean,
is that what's going to happen or are we going to blow ourselves up before we
get there are these old old fuck heads hanging on by kitty cat claws on a
curtain just barely hanging on.
They hit the red button and the whole thing gets wiped back to 10,000 years ago.
Again,
I am an optimist,
so I hope that's not our future in our future,
uh,
plans.
But I,
I think that,
that the way things are going now,
we're not in control of our country.
The people of America are not in cool wheels specifically.
Well,
that's a good question because obviously it's not the presidency because
otherwise NDA wouldn't have been passed and we wouldn't have this ridiculous war
on,
on whistleblowers.
And journalists who went to improve the country.
So you think the presidency has,
that's definitely not within what they're looking for?
Um,
no.
And,
and I think that,
um,
I,
because it can't be anymore.
I mean if Obama passed a signed NDA with,
with those kind of provisions to be able to detain a American citizens without
trial,
that violates the Fifth Amendment,
uh,
it's no longer in on behalf of the people.
I don't think they're making decisions on behalf of the people.
You have some people that speculate who's really in control.
Some people say the Federal Reserve,
uh,
that,
that worries them significantly.
Uh,
that's where we borrow most of our money.
No one really knows who's in charge of the Federal Reserve.
Some people say they're the ones pulling the strings.
Um,
you hear all these conspiracy theories.
but,
but one thing's for sure is,
is the people of the United States.
I feel personally based on my last 10 years of really getting behind the scenes
and investigating,
uh,
all of these major disasters we've had in the country,
the people are no longer in control.
Decisions are not being made on behalf of the people.
If decisions are being made on behalf of the people,
the United States,
we would not be about to be entering Iran.
We would be taking that money and giving it toward education and health care and
improving the economy.
If decisions were being made on behalf of the people,
we'd be going after the bankers that got us in this mess.
What's staggering to me is that if you look at what we're doing overseas,
where we're spending all this money,
this,
a lot of the,
the contracts that have gone to Halliburton for reconstruction,
a lot of the different desalination plants they have over there,
we could have easily had businesses profiting off of government contracts to fix
our infrastructure,
to fix our bad communities,
to fix our impoverished places,
to try to heal up America.
I've always said that the best way,
if you want to make America better,
the best way to do it is make less losers.
Right?
So the way to make less than later,
you got to go after you.
You have to try to help children.
You have to try to brace poor neighborhoods and try to prop them up and try to
figure out a way to,
you know,
to bring some sort of economic prosperity to that area in education.
Help people work,
give them role models you get,
there's,
there's money to be made and their satisfaction to be gained from the people
that could help those people.
That's like a beautiful human experience of helping people out and propping them
up.
And it can be profitable because these is going to have to,
there's guys that have to spend money doing that,
so corporations are gonna make money.
Tax dollars will go there.
It seems like it's just sort of a redistribution for,
you know,
of,
of the way we're spending our money from spending it on war to spending it on
love.
And it seems like there's money in love too,
but we've been tricked into thinking there's only money in war and to think that
all of our resources and everything that we have and everything that we project
can only be profitable if we're killing people.
That seems crazy.
It seems like that's just,
no,
that's just the way we've always been doing it and in viewing the world as one
giant community,
which I think is inevitable.
I'm pretty sure if you just look at the way things are going,
the exponential growth,
it's inevitable.
It's inevitable that we will be just one big world community.
Well,
that's what we've got to do.
It's real simple.
If we want to live and enjoy life,
which I assume everyone does,
we'd want to enjoy this life.
The only way we can enjoy this life is if there's the smallest amount of people
possible that are not enjoying it.
Small,
small,
the smallest amount of people in despair that that,
that it's manageable.
The smallest amount of you're always going to have a certain amount of losers.
He always going to have a certain amount.
As long as there's variables,
as long as there is you could do,
you could go left whenever you want to go,
right?
We're just going to be mistakes.
There's going to be chaos,
which were human,
human or humans are nuts.
But if we could drop that to the tiny,
minuscule number and the amount of oppressed people make it as small as
possible,
the amount of people with no opportunity to make it as small as possible,
then we can have a beautiful world for everybody.
But we're not going to get that by supporting Bahrain.
We're not going to get that by,
by guarding poppy fields and Afghanistan.
We're not going to get that by multibillion dollar,
no bid contracts for Halliburton.
That is not how we're going to get there we are.
That's the last gasps of a dying empire of Douche bags.
You know?
And that's what I really,
when I look at this country and when I look at like all these people that are
speaking out,
when I look at people like you,
I see real patriotism.
When I see people like Alex,
you can tell I call Alex Jones crazy all day.
I love that guy.
And he's a fucking patriot and he's a real patriot.
And what he wants isn't not to expose corruption and conspiracy everywhere he
goes.
What he wants is for all the stop.
He wants to run this country with a real sense of morals.
We should be run by true.
More or less,
we'd be who should be run by people who feel responsible for their actions,
who feel that the,
the repercussions of the decisions that they make should be as positive as
possible.
And we should be a nation of heroes.
We should lead the world as a nation of heroes instead of marauders.
Know,
do people deserve better?
You know,
I,
I've twirled deserves better world deserves better.
Yes,
the world deserves to know that,
that people are going to be in the best interest.
We need to know that we can be run by the best possible examples of humanity and
that we,
we could encounter the best possible examples of humanity in every single
country.
If people just rise,
if people just get their fucking shit together,
you,
you unanimously all across the board.
If we can figure out a way to truly enlightened and the way to do this,
as with mushrooms,
see what we're doing right now,
ladies and gentlemen,
we're,
we're fucking around and we're trying to do it on our own.
And it's too goddamn hard.
You only get so far with a yoga class every six months that you squeeze in after
Starbucks,
a fucking heart attack when you're bending over and warrior posts.
I think we need mushrooms and we need them now.
We need them from outerspace.
We need them to just drop down just well,
we need something.
We need an enlightenment.
We need,
we need the next stage of enlightenment.
We surely do.
And it seems inevitable.
And it seems like there's a battle going on and there's a lot of people that
believe that you can't have the,
the true push and momentum of enlightenment and less this resistance against it.
It said,
our whole,
our,
our entire nature is that we,
we really don't achieve what we can achieve unless there's resistance.
And so we,
we still have somehow in our alpha male primate DNA,
this desire to conquer and this desire to,
uh,
to,
fight against oppression,
this desire to rise against the enemy and compete against your,
your fellow man.
And it's almost like a lot of people believe that the only way for people to
truly achieve enlightenment is to see a Holocaust,
is to see an inquisition,
is to see like the horrific possibilities of humanity.
So it gives us something to not be,
you know,
it gives us something to rise against.
You know,
I think that's the past though.
I think.
I think really the future,
I think we were living in a weird world award.
We're living in a world that has changed a lot more than we're aware of and it's
slowly starting to creep up on us
enemy.
I mean,
who knows if,
if we've already missed this,
the warning signs.
But that's why people need to take it so seriously when we have NDAs past and
when we see police dressed like judge Dredd.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean this wake up,
look what's happening
on our streets of this country.
We think of 10 years ago,
if you saw those police officers dressed like judge Dredd standing in front of a
protest in front of Walmart,
intimidating a bunch of older individuals who are unarmed.
Yeah.
And it is scary.
And it all could've been avoided.
It all could've been avoided if the police were different.
It all could have been avoided if that kid was not shot in front of everybody in
broad daylight.
It all could've been avoided if the police reacted to it differently.
Everything could have been avoided.
Instead,
it's,
fuck you.
You do as we say,
or we're going to bring in tanks and dogs and rubber bullets,
and that's not America.
Well,
it's not.
It's you're being lazy.
You're doing it the wrong way.
You're trying to just control things and you're,
you're,
you're not doing it the way that an enlightened society and culture would handle
it.
You're not.
And,
and that means that's the enemy,
that,
that type of behavior.
They'd marching down the streets and shooting bullets down the alley.
That's,
that's the enemy.
That's the enemy at home.
And the people that are doing it,
they think that they're doing well.
They think they're doing good.
They think they're doing their,
their job.
And that's what's really fucked up about it.
It's like by,
by the fact that someone gives them the green light,
they feel like they're in the right,
you know,
well this fucker protesters,
you start breaking the law and I'll stop shooting rubber bullets at their face.
Like it's,
you know,
just because somebody wrote something down on a piece of paper doesn't mean that
Shit's right.
You know?
I mean,
there's a lot of shit that's written down on paper that doesn't make any sense.
And one of the things is that you're somehow allowed to bring tanks into a city
and guys with machine guns because a kid got shot in the back.
That's not the way you're supposed to handle that situation.
That's not the way an enlightened being in handles their society and their
culture.
And that is where we are right now.
We are,
we're at a up a pass and human nature.
We were at a a bridge.
We're at a divide where we have to change from the way we've lived for the past
few thousand years.
We just lived like dominating creeps.
We have to change into a compassionate side society of people who view each
other as a community.
You know,
people who view everyone all around the world as a community.
And that's,
that's the only hope.
It's the only hope for humanity.
And it seems to me that's like almost a race is a race between the,
the assholes of the world that are trying to start conflict everywhere they can
and try and extract resources and just fuck people over.
There's a race between them and enlightenment,
you know,
and one on one of the,
one of them is going to win,
you know,
one of them is going to win and either they get to the button first and they
fuck flipped the whole board over and we have to start the game over again.
Or we calm everything the fuck down and we get out of this and we realize that
you can't do all this corrupt bullshit anymore.
Everybody knows what you're doing now.
And now we have to have a government that actually looks out for people and we
have to make decisions based on what's an intelligent way to look at our
possibilities for the future and that's what leaders are supposed to do and
that's what real patriotism is supposed to be about.
It's not supposed to be about locking people up because they expose when you
fuck up.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
we're just at a time right now where I agree with you.
That was a beautiful way to describe it,
Joe,
where we are,
we're competing.
Enlightenment is competing with corruption and you're seeing corruption slowly
try to crush enlightenment by with Nda,
with a prosecuting whistleblowers and,
and who's going to win.
And I,
I'm always on the side of the people.
I think that I think a growing number of people are realizing what's happening,
but it can only happen if you let it happen to yourself.
Nda,
closest eggs.
The best example of that,
that there is a battle going on because in,
in just in the language that they use,
saying that they can hold you indefinitely without recourse,
that alone is like saying no,
I have God mode.
That's like saying it's bringing someone into God.
Note.
That's your fuck the MBA.
Yeah.
I had to create the meme.
I,
we've had to,
as journalists,
we've had to also become activists when we seen the truth because we,
we are enlightened in a way that most of the public isn't.
And,
and,
and now it's such a critical time.
I just felt like I had to get that out there to let people know.
As journalist we say,
fuck this section of the NDA.
This is ridiculous.
It is a power to kill journalism because it will tear up our sources from coming
forward.
Not only that,
we could be accused of helping terrorist whoever our government decides are
terrorists and get locked up forever.
And Obama says he won't use it on US citizens.
He promises that.
But what about the next president and the president after that?
You know that old expression,
the person you say yes to today won't be the same person you say yes to 20 years
from now.
Yeah,
and that's the problem with law is that,
you know,
just because someone puts something into once it's down,
once it's written in the book,
it can be interpreted a number of different ways and use a number of different
ways.
As you're seeing in Bahrain where they're killing people with sanctioned methods
of crowd control.
They're using it to execute people,
you know,
slowly with sanction methods of crowd control,
their disusing the law and they using it
to their advantage of tear gas.
I mean they are,
if anyone researches that they're systematically gassing these people and if
they continue this way,
doctors are terrified for the longterm health damage is going to have.
They're just gassing hundreds of thousands of people over and over every single
day,
10 minutes from the U s military base.
Why aren't our troops complaining about this?
We need,
they see this every day.
Yeah.
Why aren't they?
Well,
I don't think they have.
What,
what can the troops do?
Yeah,
well they can't,
they can't be,
oh,
if they all came up and rebelled against what was happening on the,
down the street from them and spoke out against it,
it couldn't exist.
Well,
one of the things that they do to keep the troops down as a Cuban poor,
you know,
the,
the money that they make while in the military is shockingly low.
And the,
the scary thing is that when Dick was in office,
they passed laws that allow them to send people back.
You know,
even if your time is over,
they can bring you back because they need bodies.
And it's scary.
It's scary for those people.
I have a friend that was,
uh,
he was 20 days.
He had 20 days left on a 20 year stint in the army reserves and they sent him to
Iraq for a year and a half and they sent him back again and sent them there for
a year and a half.
And then they sent him back again later.
Uh,
you know,
this guy was fucked.
There was nothing to do about it.
He had 20 days left.
Wow.
Yeah.
When they go tough shit,
see Yah,
we can do it.
You gonna fight us.
You're going to fight her so you going to do what we tell you to do.
And they have,
they,
they have those guys programmed to do what they tell them to do and they're
scared and they don't have money to fight it in court and they don't want to get
court marshaled and they know that the,
the law is not on their side.
The,
the written law is not on their side.
Even though it's morally,
it doesn't make sense.
It's,
Legally.
None of it makes sense that you can actually have these,
I mean,
essentially you turn people into slaves.
He turned that day,
you have to do your bidding.
They do your bidding for a minimal amount of money and it's shit.
It's fucking shocking.
It's shocking.
It's,
it's,
it's Orwellian.
It's disappointing.
It's when you realize that this is how the country really is run and our
idealistic view of it as America,
fuck yeah.
It's just,
it's not,
it's not what it could be.
It's like we're embarrassing.
If you look at the amount of goodwill that we had after nine 11,
you know,
and everybody was like,
fun.
Well,
we're our hearts.
Go out to America.
This is a horrible tragedy.
And then look at the way they look at us now.
Like God damn,
whatever we did,
whatever we did to deserve that is,
it's just a mess.
So it wouldn't,
we're not as good as we could be,
just not period would clearly we've been running and competently.
And I thought Obama was going to be able to do some about that.
Yeah.
So did I,
uh,
I think a lot of people felt that the country would change and journalistically
it's changed horrifically.
So,
so that only tells you,
uh,
I mean,
like I said earlier,
that,
that the presidency is no longer in control by the individual.
Um,
you know,
I feel like there are greater forces at play here and,
and our country is being led in a direction that's not in the direction that
people want it to go.
So,
so what's going to happen here?
You know,
w
the crazy thing is if they do do something when I ran the can't expect,
they'll be no repercussions.
I mean,
what are they,
what do they think is going to be the blowback?
What do they think is going to be the,
you know,
the aftershock,
the aftermath,
what did,
how much damage is something like that going to cause internationally if Russia
and China get involved,
it could be crazy.
Yeah.
It can be worried recurring world war three and they have nukes,
you know,
and um,
and,
and I'm not,
I don't want to be sitting here fearmongering but,
but I see the writings on the wall,
you just have to look at all the,
the,
the propaganda being fed and of the fact
that bufferin was so systematically censored,
that story and all of the mainstream media,
not just CNN.
And so you look at that,
put everything,
put the pieces of the puzzle together.
And to me it spells out war and,
um,
and the American people need to wake up and realize that we are,
we are close to two action being taken now.
Is it going to be taken with the approval of,
of the people?
Are we going to be given a choice?
And it's pretty scary that I'm even having to ask this question now.
Do you remember when Obama was running for office and they were saying,
we're gonna,
he's gonna pull out of Iraq,
is going to close down Guantanamo Bay.
He had all these things that he was saying that there's none of that
sign,
Nda hell,
take that out.
Yeah,
but there's none of that talk now in this series of debates.
It's all about the economy and it's all about business and it's all about taxes.
Meanwhile,
we're about to go into world war three and we're like,
okay,
la,
La,
I'm not listening.
We're like completely blocking out.
Like four years ago it was,
it was huge.
That was the,
the entire discussion was what are we doing with these wars that we can't win?
You know,
when are we going to pull out what?
How are we going to handle this?
You know,
Mccain had one plan,
Obama had another,
Obama was going to get us out of there.
And it seemed like we had realize as a country that we were going to have to
correct the mistakes of the previous administration,
but now that doesn't seem to be any of that talk.
They've just swept that under the rug.
It's almost like they're denying that a,
there's still a huge conflict going on in Afghanistan.
We're still,
to this day,
people are suicide bombing left and right is all sorts of troops that we train
are attacking Americans and using the guns that we give them on American
soldiers means fucking chaos over there.
And there's not a peep about it.
Not a peep,
not a peep,
not a people about the heroin on a peep about the fact that Afghanistan controls
more than 90% of the world's heroine and that heroin use has gone up,
skyrocketed in the United States since our,
since our occupation in Afghanistan.
And some of that is going towards,
uh,
to make oxycontin yeah.
And painkillers that are causing a ridiculous number of addicts and Florida in
Appalachia
in that documentary.
The oxycontin express.
Yeah.
And I,
yeah,
it was fabulous.
I am a huge fan of,
of her,
uh,
Marianna van Zeller.
I'm Darren foster.
Did that one for current.
They are extremely talented film producers in general.
That was scary shit when you watch that guy whose wife died of an overdose and
he smoked oxycontin before he called the cops while his wife was dead next to
him.
It's crazy.
My cousin's in jail right now for that.
Um,
he grew up in like a upper middle class family in the suburbs and he got hooked
on Oxycontin after trying it at a party,
then switched to heroin and out.
And now he's in the,
in the slammer.
Unfortunately
I have a family member who lost it shit over it,
got injured gut,
you know,
had a back injury,
took it and just lost it.
Gone.
Not the same guy anymore.
Now he's gone.
Just nuts.
And it's scary,
scary,
scary drug and so easy to get.
Just unbelievably easy to get.
And what people don't realize is that there's more addicts,
more pill addicts today than there have ever been at any time in human history.
I mean,
there's more people that are hooked on these fucking crazy pain pills.
it's an epidemic,
a real epidemic.
Meanwhile,
the DDA is fucking going after medical marijuana,
fucking breaking down doors and stick a machine.
Guns and tie dyed kid tee shirt faces.
You know,
it's,
it's fucking unbelievable.
I love going to Venice beach when you can just walk there and you just see
people just smoking a joint on the side.
And not just because I'm,
I'm,
I'm not saying whether I'm a marijuana fan or not,
but I'm saying that your marijuana fan,
I,
you know,
I don't,
I don't see the problem with it.
I'm going to come out the problem because I've covered the oxycontin.
I did a lot of reporting from Florida.
I saw my family member affected by it and I said,
this is legal and America and marijuana is illegal.
If you look at the side effects will juke Dr drew on fucking CNN tried to say
that there was a massive withdrawal effects the coincide with quitting
marijuana,
which is complete physiological nonsense.
It's just not true.
There's no withdrawal.
It's not like heroin.
It's not like you can die.
You know?
You know what?
As the worst withdrawal alcohol,
people die because they don't drink.
You get so addicted to alcohol that if you go cold Turkey,
you're body can go into shock and you can die.
It's not marijuana stupid and he's on CNN talking about that.
You know,
talking about marijuana being something dangerous only to pussies.
Marijuana fucks up your life.
I've always said this,
it's just because marijuana got there first.
It could have been cheeseburgers,
scratch tickets.
It could have been anything.
You're,
you're,
you're an idiot.
You,
you let something that makes people happy.
It makes me more sensitive,
makes people,
it makes food taste better.
You've made that ruin your life.
If that's,
you could ruin your life with anything if you so choose.
People are weird.
People get addicted to washing their hands.
People get addicted to sitting in front of shows and not leaving when the
commercials on people are nuts.
Like you can't,
can't say cause a certain amount of people can't handle marijuana,
marijuana with do a lot of people that are in control of this world.
Some good just to be paranoid and just think about the repercussions and think
about the,
the actions that they've done and what,
what that's caused to the,
the,
the people that they have control over.
Maybe you should give a Netanyahu a joint upon Kootenay,
Hella young who would cry if you gave that guy a pot Brownie and it just net
zero Yahoo.
Yeah.
He's uh,
he would change his cartoon bomb for sure.
He would make it like the desk squad transplant had to be stoned when they,
when they drew that bomb because it's so ridiculous.
I just can't imagine someone with an under the influence of some type of drug.
It's,
it's during that drawing.
Well,
it makes me think that this world is not real.
You know,
I,
I go over this so many times that my,
my fans are getting angry at me sometimes at Twitter.
Me and tell me,
stop talking about simulation theory because it really starts it.
When you saw Mitt Romney the other day and he was wearing black face when he's
talking to the Mexicans,
I was like,
Holy Shit,
this can't be real.
That guy put fucking sneaky tan on his face and he's,
he didn't even get it on his neck.
He didn't get it on the back of his neck.
So as his face is all like super brown and orange t his neck is white,
his neck looks like a fucking tee shirt.
Dude,
I,
I've lived in Mexico and Guatemala and he is not Hispanic.
I don't care what he says or if he wants to try to fit in.
Well,
you know,
it's,
it's a shame.
Yeah.
He's from Mexico.
I,
I've heard some,
I've heard different theories on that,
that,
that um,
that they were kind of forced down there.
His family.
Yeah,
they're polygamists.
they wanted to fuck a lot of women.
They wanted to have a bunch of wives and so they wouldn't let them do it in
America.
So they decided to move to Mexico.
But that was back when people were riding horses or ride.
Nobody thought there was gonna be a difference.
What's the difference?
Mexico.
America.
Fuck it.
Let's move there.
Yeah,
we can have 10 wives there.
And so they decided to move there and Mexico just didn't change and grow at the
same rate as America.
So now they're stuck in like wars and shootouts with the drug cartels.
And the guys from vice,
um,
broke the story about the Mormon compound.
Uh,
the Romney compound that they have down in Mexico,
there's the Romney family is from fucking Mexico.
Romney's dad wanted to run for president,
but he couldn't because he was born in Mexico in a cult.
And that's where Romney came from.
He came from there.
He lived there.
I mean,
it's fucking bananas.
They,
there are a crazy loony,
toons religious cult that wanted a bunch of wives.
And so they decided to go to another country.
And,
and I,
I hate when candidates try to act like they're so chum chum with,
with the black community or the Latino community are,
you know,
they always put a show on.
It's just so disingenuous.
And,
and the way I see him do that with the,
with the Hispanic community is just ridiculous.
You know,
I don't see him by hanging out in,
you know,
NLA and,
and really,
you know,
really getting down with the community.
I could ever imagine him going in a bar and hanging out with,
with a bunch of day labor,
Hispanic men I could never see them getting along with,
with Romney.
It's interesting though that that's where the,
uh,
the,
the debate has gone.
That's where the focus of our country has gone.
It's gone into these two very different personalities and what each one
represents.
And then the dialogue is one of them represents a redistribution of wealth.
He represents,
you know,
he's going to take money from these,
these people that have worked so hard.
He's going to give it to these lazy folk to try to prop them up.
And then the other side is that this,
this guy is a businessman and this guy is going to be able to figure out what's
wrong with the business of this economy.
Put us back on track and he's got these steps that he's going to take right
away.
And then the one size like this is going to cost the middle class a lot of money
and all while this is going on,
tanks are moving into place.
Uh,
right now that's neuron Iran,
Iran,
and,
and I,
the more I look at it,
the more I'm,
I'm starting to agree with people who,
who think that the two party system is just a distraction.
Go Hixon it passed.
Yeah.
He said,
uh,
I liked that.
He goes,
he goes,
I locked the puppet on the left.
Well,
the pub on the ride is more to my liking.
Hey,
wait a minute.
One guy was holding both puppets,
you know,
and that's essentially the dog and pony show that we got going on.
Gay Rights,
redistribution of wealth.
So what my taxes,
what are you going to do?
Give it to one of the lazy welfare people.
You know,
there's a people that believe that welfare is in place just simply to ensure
that there's a certain amount of democratic voters every year.
Now they just continue the welfare.
So people continue to be on the Dole.
So people continue to support.
Anybody supports that.
It's a mess.
It's a fucking mass.
So what gives you hope?
I always ask people that want marijuana.
Psychedelics can,
excuse
me,
help.
But for real,
I'm not joking.
It sounds ridiculous because people associate psychedelics with uh,
with non realistic things,
with hallucinations.
They,
they,
they don't look at it the way I look at it.
I think that there are certain plants here that have aided in the evolution of
human consciousness.
The have changed the way people look.
They've changed the way I look at people.
They've changed my relationship with human beings.
My,
the way I look at human beings has fundamentally changed by having psychedelic
experiences and change for the better.
Made me a healthier,
nicer person,
made me more loving and made me more aware of the consequences of my own
personal actions.
And I think that's one of the reasons why they illegal and I think it's a
really,
it's a shame that they've been derided to the point where it's,
it's a laughable topic,
you know?
If you say,
well,
you know,
yeah,
Rogan also thinks that mushrooms can cure mankind.
Well guess what?
They could,
if we all had really intense mushroom trips,
first of all,
people would come out of that with a complete reset.
They come out with that you would be healthy,
but you would have a complete reset of the way you view eternity.
The way you view this situation,
that we're in the,
we're so caught up in our own little culture and our own little situation that
we have constructed and that we're fighting against and trying to control these
various aspects that we don't even,
we don't even think.
We don't take the time to think about the incredible majesty of just life itself
and how amazing it is and how incredible it is that you have friends and loved
ones and how incredible it is that you can have sex and that you could drink
wine,
you could eat steak and you could go to a movie and you can drive a car.
We'd live in a fucking fantasy world and I think that if people had some new
found appreciation,
whether it's a near death experiences,
whether it's from a psychedelics with,
it's from meditation,
whatever it is,
I think people operate their lives primarily on momentum.
They get up the same way.
They've always gotten up,
they move in the same way.
They've moved to get there every day to work,
and they go through the same job every day.
And that momentum is very,
very difficult to break.
And even if it's not a healthy momentum,
whether it's,
you know,
beating off to your Dick Bleeds or gambling all your money away,
we still get stuck in that momentum that I got to me.
I need a drink.
You don't even know why you need a drink.
You're stuck in some wacky momentum.
You could call it being addicted to porn.
You could call it being addicted to the Internet,
but we're stuck in a wacky momentum.
And the only thing in my experience that changes that is a complete
reconstruction of how you view the world.
And the only way to do that is to step away.
You have to have some sort of a,
a disconnect,
some sort of a,
uh,
an experience where you get an objective look at things for the first time.
You look at things as if you were someone completely unattached to every single
aspect of your life and the lives of all the people around with you.
But you get to see it like mapped out in front of you clearly and cleanly with
no ego,
with no financial repercussions with no,
just you get to really see what it is.
And that's not fucking possible for most people without some form of psychedelic
experience.
And so when you do these,
because this is you,
you saw my first reaction was to laugh cool.
And you know,
everybody's is,
yeah,
I know.
Even I,
it just,
I've never really heard of it.
Describe this way.
So tell me,
when you do the mushrooms,
what,
what does it do?
What does it like in,
in your mind,
what are you experiencing that allows you to have a greater understanding of
reality?
Well,
that's where it gets really tricky because some people don't experience that.
They just experienced terror and dancing mice and alligator people that want to
eat your ass.
Like you get to have bad trips too.
It's not,
yeah,
it's not always rosy
has,
I've never done any,
any drugs like that.
So I,
I've,
because I've always had that fear of,
of something fatal happening or,
well,
Mckenna felt the term.
There's a guy named Terrence Mckenna who was,
um,
one of my psychedelic heroes and his original,
really brilliant,
a fascinating human being.
And he had this crazy theory,
um,
called the stoned ape theory.
And it was his belief that it's since psychedelic drugs unquestionably have
existed since the beginning of human civilization.
There have been various sacraments,
various things that people have taken in during rituals.
To the point where a guy named John Marco Allegro is one of the scholars that
described the Dakota,
the dead,
the Dead Sea Scrolls.
One of his translation,
his uh,
his one,
he wrote two books about the translations.
One of them is called the sacred mushroom and the cross and the,
his book,
what was his basic life's work was explaining was that the entire Christian
religion was a massive misunderstanding.
And what it was really all about was psychedelic mushroom rituals and fertility
cults.
And that this was how the original co group of,
of,
of people like this,
they wrote down all these rituals in the form of parables,
in the form of stories.
And I mean it's,
you have to be some sort of a scholar and you know,
in Aramaic and in ancient languages to even understand what the fuck he's saying
to when you would disagree with it.
But no question they had psychedelic mushrooms.
There's no question.
And there's no question that they thought that those psychedelic mushrooms were
a direct connection to God.
And that's probably what represented God to them.
And that they didn't want other people to know about it.
And so they hid those things.
They hit those things and stories.
And those stories didn't represent necessarily Santa Claus or rep and various
people that Jesus,
one of the things that he translated was he believed that the word Jesus,
or the word Christ rather meant a mushroom covered in God's seaman and said he
believed that this was a Sumerian word apparently.
And he believed that we were,
they thought that when it rained that it was God like having intercourse with
the earth and that these mushrooms would grow out of the ground like overnight.
And you know,
we,
they didn't have microscopes so they couldn't see the,
uh,
the,
the spores that turned into mushrooms.
So they thought that this was like gifts from God,
then they would take them and trip.
They're fucking balls off.
So if you really stop and think about that,
if you lived in a time where there was no science and virtually no understanding
of the world that we live in and you found mushrooms and you ate them and just
had this fucking mind blowing,
transcending experience,
Mckenna believed that that was responsible for us evolving past lower hominids.
He believed that the the doubling of the human brain size over a period of 2
million years,
which is a huge mystery in the fossil record,
they don't really understand why the human brain size doubled and it was his
theory that they doubled because they started taking psychedelic mushrooms and
these monkeys came down off the trees.
They started eating mushrooms every day and in doing that it changed the co
sure.
Your skin,
you're going to scare her away,
Joe.
It's no,
none at all.
I'm actually,
I'm,
it's fascinating stuff,
dude,
if you will.
I don't have to tell you,
you've,
you've had many mushrooms trips,
but when you have them,
there's,
it's such a powerful experience.
If I'm going to rob a bank,
I'm still going to rob a bank.
If I do mushrooms or not,
if I'm going to rape somebody,
I'm going to,
I'm going to share my mushrooms to go,
you know what,
I'm not going to rape this girl anymore.
I'm like,
I don't think mushrooms fixes anything.
I think if everyone did mushrooms all road,
it's not going to fix anyone cause you look at it
keyless,
first of all you,
you might be very different than a lot of people that have had transcending
experience mushrooms.
I Bet Brian does.
Yeah.
They might be fucked up to begin with,
but you can't discount all the positive experiences and all the transcendent
experiences that people have had.
Yes.
You asked like two days.
No,
it lasts two days for you.
I don't think about a mushroom trip after two days now.
Okay,
well that's you Brian.
Basically you
sit there and say every day we wake up,
like thinking about how we argue about it.
It's just silly that you're even arguing about it.
So what does it do to you when you take mushrooms?
Like I know you guys say it's like a delicate,
what do you see?
What do you,
what are your like profound experiences,
what he's saying?
I think in saying that you think about it for two days is that for two days you
sort of reconsider yourself and then you eventually go back into the pattern of
your everyday life,
right?
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah.
It doesn't do anything permanent where it's like,
okay I'm going to always,
I'm going to be a better person.
Okay.
But that is,
that is extremely subjective and it does to other people and it has to me.
So when you say that it doesn't,
I say okay maybe to you,
but for you to say that just because you haven't had a life changing experience
where they've pushed you into a different direction of understanding,
it doesn't mean it doesn't exist.
What I'm telling you that it exists for me and there's two of us,
so it's 50% of the people in this room that have done mushrooms when I was
getting at is I don't think if you had everyone do,
cause you say this all the time about if everyone just did mushrooms,
everything will fix itself.
I don't think for most people,
mushrooms has that big of an effect after a couple of days,
you know,
because because of momentum,
I think that's because of momentum and because of the fact that it's so easy to
go back and to think about your life the way you used to think about it before
you had that experience.
Your Ego will guide you right back to the patterns that you're comfortable in
anywhere.
You know?
Unless you've chosen,
look what makes a person decide,
you know,
I'm tired of being a fat fuck.
I am.
I am going to start eating healthy and I'm going to drink water all day and I'm
going to lose this fucking weight.
For some people it's bullshit.
They try it and then two days later they go back to eating again.
I mean,
Brian,
you've been on several diets where you've lost a tremendous amount of weight and
then you go back to your normal patterns of eating.
Right.
I'm in on one diet,
but yeah.
Okay.
You've been,
I thought it was more than once,
but he lost it.
He lost an amazing amount of weight,
like 80 80 something pounds.
But then that would motivation because I got out,
have a relationship at eight year relationship.
See,
you had a transcendent experience.
You had something that made you change your life and for some people that
mushroom trip that that reset,
they might have more questions about life than you do.
They might have more questions about their own consciousness than you do and
when they have those psychedelic experiences,
they're truly life changing.
And it doesn't have to be just for two days.
It can be for two days.
I've never starts you in a direction.
I guess.
I've never met anyone that did mushrooms and it changed their life forever ever.
Cause you know me.
Yeah,
I wouldn't think that though.
A lot of people do.
That's weird.
You know Greg Fitzsimmons when he was on the podcast,
he was talking about how much I've changed since he met with a lot of that is
psychedelic experiences,
man.
I mean a lot of that is meditation.
A lot of that is tiny isolation tech heads.
You say aids age to that too,
by the way,
that is all life experiences and psychedelic experiences are part of life
experiences.
They're unbelievably introspective.
They force
you to examine your life and,
and really almost an alien way.
And again,
not for everybody.
Different people go into them with different baggage,
you know,
different people.
Some people try to fight the experience and go crazy.
And um,
there's,
there are certain aspects to the psychedelic experience where you cannot control
it.
You don't have any control over it.
But what,
what it does do for sure is humbles people.
And what it does do for sure is it squashes your ego,
you know,
and maybe Brian doesn't have ego problems.
Maybe that's why,
you know,
it doesn't change him that much.
But for some people it's incredibly humble.
It's just really cool.
Like you get some cool movies and put it on,
it's really neat.
But I think that's about the height of it.
Well,
I totally disagree and there's 50% of us here,
so it's like,
look,
everybody's different.
Some people eat peanuts and it fucking kills them.
I'm wearing with.
Okay.
Do I try it or do I know?
Or,
um,
if you wanted to do something,
what I would recommend is I'm going to Peru and doing like an Iowasca retreat to
one of those.
I scuba dive.
I do something.
Yeah.
Jerry Garcia said he wouldn't need,
you wouldn't need hallucinogenics if he was able to scuba dive everyday because
to me,
that's,
that's when you're seeing all the coral formations and this crazy huge fish and
sharks coming at you.
That to me is another world experience.
That's exactly the say for Jerry Garcia after he did acid a billion times
at certain point in time.
Where you even sober after that?
I mean,
do you ever get sober or who allowed him to scuba dive?
I wouldn't want to be as scuba buddy.
He's a fucking,
just gonna die any second on you?
That guy's held together by tissue paper.
Yeah.
How old was he when he was scuba diving?
Uh,
I think it was,
I think it was later in his life,
but not,
not too late,
but,
uh,
but that's just a well known phrase within scuba diving that,
that he would always say that,
especially when he was able to go down,
like in places like Hawaii where you have turtles and,
and that's like tripping when you see a turtle swimming right next to you and
you're swimming and you're at the same pace and it's this huge,
huge sea turtle.
It's awesome.
Yeah.
I love,
love,
love seeing sharks.
Uh,
because they're so rare.
It's very rare to,
it's like saying you're,
you go hiking out in California,
you'll see a bear.
It's,
it's almost,
the odds are slim to none.
So when I get to see a shark,
I'm,
I get excited about it.
At one time we were a scuba diving below the oil spill on CNN.
This is really cool that they,
they let us do this.
And um,
and there was an area where there weren't a lot of bait fish because they'd been
killed by the oil.
So we're down underneath the water.
It was me and Felipe Cousteau.
Jacques Cousteau invented scuba diving.
It was his grandson and Jacques Cousteau invented scuba diving.
Uh,
he,
uh,
yeah,
he,
he helped.
Oh really?
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
Sorry.
Thanks a lot guys who we had that show,
but I didn't know it affected it.
Wow.
Um,
are you being serious?
Are you,
oh,
I thought you were really didn't know that one guy invented scuba dive.
Well,
he helped he,
I mean,
but who knows if we can trust what was written.
He helped innovate it.
Uh,
I'd say he was really the guy who brought it to the mainstream and,
and so we were there alive on TV,
scuba diving,
and all of a sudden there's sharks swimming behind us on Erin.
A lot of viewers thought we were going to get eaten.
And um,
and,
and so I was really paying attention to,
we were wearing hazmat suits and I was paying attention to not drowning cause my
suit had flooded and there was,
we're an oily water.
And so I barely noticed the sharks,
but I went back and watched the video and,
and there are a lot of them that just keeps swimming right past us.
And I later find out that our,
um,
my asshole South African photographer was throwing lunch meat off the boat that
was attracting all these sharks to come toward us.
I know.
Yeah.
He was throwing a,
we had Walmart sandwiches and he was,
he was throwing this alarm you and the Baloney that he didn't like off the boat
and it attracted one shark and he thought it was funny too to bring all these
other sharks on board,
but I'm bag.
But it's cool to see them underwater.
There are fascinating creatures the way they swim and,
and also,
um,
just to see something that massive that could potentially harm you.
It's kind of a adrenaline rush,
you know?
Yeah,
for sure.
Actually.
Uh,
it's,
it doesn't seem like they invented it.
It seems like Jacques Cousteau sort of,
um,
made it,
uh,
made it popular,
but it seems like the first,
uh,
inventions of it.
We're in the 17 hundreds,
17,
71,
a British engineer named John Smeaton invented the air pump and the hose was
connected between the air pump and uh,
uh,
a diving barrel allowing air to be pumped to the diver.
So in 1700,
they invented it.
People are so crafty.
I know I'm going amazing
and it's pretty fascinating to be underwater and be able to breathe and yeah.
Uh,
it,
it's one of the most incredible feelings.
I highly recommend scuba diving chicken Marsala fabric.
No,
I,
well I'm not,
I'm not a claustrophobic person,
so it doesn't affect me in that way,
but um,
but I could see how some people would affect them because you have all this gear
on and you're relying on this claustrophobic thing over your mouth to be able to
breathe.
Yeah.
It seems like if something goes bad,
it goes bad fast.
You know,
like if you see like a shark or something like that you've lived in,
just start panicking.
That's you,
dude.
That's,
that seems like it would.
No,
I mean like she's got it together,
Dude.
She's in Bahrain,
getting machine guns put in her head.
She can handle sharks.
I have an abnormal sense of fear.
I know I don't.
My whole life I,
I just don't have that thing in my brain that tells me,
wait,
stop what you're doing.
Really?
Yeah.
It's,
it's strange.
I just,
it doesn't,
if I do have it,
it's very,
very minimal.
Have you ever thought that maybe you have like a destiny and that the reason why
you have this bizarre abnormal sense of fear where you don't react to it?
It's because this is your path.
Maybe you're like a historical figure.
Some day,
some day I'll be able to do,
they're going to be talking about you.
It's going to be super important and you're just like this crazy broad who just,
uh,
didn't have this fear of sharks
here.
Like machine guns.
No big deal.
Let me get back in there.
I'm trying to get a visa.
I'm trying to get back to your country where you tried to shoot me.
You know,
I mean that's a,
that's a very,
a weird possibility.
Have you ever thought about that?
Like your,
your place in this whole thing.
There's something that you said in the Alex Jones documentary that,
or a interview rather than,
I thought it was really fascinating.
You said that,
uh,
CNN is on the wrong side of history,
you know,
and um,
by,
by doing what you're doing,
you're clearly on the right side of history.
You're clearly the mean that's what you're supposed to do.
And when you see corruption,
he's supposed to talk about it.
When we see problems,
you're supposed to expose them.
You're on the right side of history.
Do you ever,
do you think about that?
Yeah,
I always,
when I come out with things full force,
um,
it's only when I,
I'm 100% know the truth.
Um,
because no matter what,
if you've,
if you follow the truth,
I always say it doesn't have a shelf life,
whatever the crops is going to get exposed.
Um,
and,
and I think that,
I think,
you know,
I really do.
I believe my,
my lack of sense of fear also,
uh,
it enabled me to do that because I don't have that thing over my shoulder
telling me,
okay,
well what if someone comes after you for going after Time Warner or what if,
um,
what if you don't have a job or money?
I've lived out of my car.
I don't,
you know,
I don't have those fears.
So that enabled me to come forward and talk about this and make and bring this
into the public light without having,
having fear.
Wow.
Where do you see this,
uh,
this all going for you?
Do you,
do,
you know,
do you have like a,
a 10 year map out where you sort of projected what,
what you're going to be doing or are you just sort of living in the moment and
trying to react to the world changing around you?
I,
um,
uh,
trying to use everything in my power to,
to enlighten Americans and let,
let them know what's happening.
Uh,
I,
I don't know yet where I'm going to be 10 years from now,
hopefully safe and sound.
And I'm working for a journalistic outlet that allows people to do real
journalism again.
Uh,
whether I have to create that or whether someone else will.
Um,
I don't know.
But,
um,
do you think that your bold choices will inspire other people that are in your
same position that we're in your same position?
Like in places like CNN and Fox News to do the same and to expose thanks.
I don't think it's,
it's really hard to do.
It's,
it's hard to do because you're,
no matter what you're going to face criticism.
And then when you look at,
at journalistically how much power these networks have and how few companies own
everything,
people don't want to tick them off and people don't want to lose their health
insurance and they don't want to lose their severance and they don't want to
lose money.
And,
um,
and it's easier just to go along every day and,
and pretend nothing's happening and,
and continue to just have that imagination that you're just a cog in the machine
and you're not really the problem.
Will every single person that's enabling this to happen is the problem.
And that's what I said.
I feel like these journalists are going to go down in on the wrong side of
history and they're just as guilty as the corporations they work for because
they know this is going on.
And they're not saying anything.
Not only are they not saying anything,
they're continuing to go into work every day and feed lies to the American
public.
Do you remember when they used to have all those movies about the McCarthy era
and,
uh,
you know that one movie with Robert De Niro,
I forget what it was,
but it just showed the suppressive nature of,
you know,
the government back then and this,
this massive witch hunt.
It's so someone and what's going on today?
It's so weird how things go in these weird,
these cycles,
these incredibly bizarre cycles.
And other witch hunt is terrorist.
The word terrorist.
Yeah.
Well,
it's,
well,
when that witch hunt becomes a guy like Julian Assange,
when it,
when it turns,
you know the word terrorism turns to a guy like Julian Assange,
everything makes you go,
well,
what is your definition?
Like,
what are you,
what are you doing?
Like this guy,
that guy has never killed anybody.
Okay.
He didn't kill anybody and he didn't lie.
So what did he do?
What did he do that so terrible?
This,
that's a terrorist.
He was a terrorist on corruption.
Hey,
Tara,
corrupt.
I'm terrified of him.
You know,
and I'm sure there's people that would consider me a terrorist because if I know
that they're corrupt,
I'm going to fucking expose them.
Be My language.
Yeah.
Um,
and exactly.
And so maybe in some people's eyes I'm a terrorist,
but that means then I can just be taken down by the NDA.
And that's what's so scary about it.
The cheating,
they're doing the wrong thing.
It's not the way you're supposed to run things.
You're fuck heads.
You know that,
you know,
you're not supposed to run things like that.
You cheating you,
you've by being,
instead of doing it correctly,
you've decided to take away all dissent.
The slowly removed the rights of the people that are showing descent.
That's some UNAMERICAN bullshit.
It can only happen if people let it happen.
Do you think it's ever possible to make a new country like the way we did
America where everybody hopped up from Europe and the like,
fuck this let's,
it was only a couple hundred years ago.
Is there a spot?
Maybe if global warming kicks in,
we could take over Greenland or Iceland rather or Antarctica,
right?
Anywhere.
Well Iceland is in that country over over there now we could uh,
maybe re colonize Mars.
That's done.
Make sense?
You know?
Or what about some type of open source government on,
you know,
on the Internet.
What about those people that want to build cities in the middle of the ocean and
international waters,
those floating city ideas?
Have you seen that?
Yeah.
Maybe that's the future.
Some fucking water world type shit.
Or we could just,
yeah,
we could just put on tanks that allow us to scuba dive to start descend into the
oceans.
I'd,
I'd prefer for that to be my faith.
I got to tell you,
Joe,
wasn't there some recent,
there's something where they allowed a,
some sort of an injection.
They allowed people to,
uh,
not have to breed for certain periods of time.
Some,
some new invention.
I actually,
I got to,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Some,
uh,
scientists,
I don't know how I should Google this.
Scientists,
uh,
swim without oxygen.
Okay.
Was that the movie at best that they pumped something in the,
you remember that shit?
Yeah.
That movie was ahead of its time,
man.
Yeah.
I don't know.
There's some new discovery.
I'm not googling it.
Aqua Fox magic.
No,
there was a,
there really was something,
a scientist suffered a way to keep people alive even when they can't breathe.
Uh,
yeah.
Okay.
They inject oxygen into the blood.
They discovered a new way of administering oxygen to the blood,
which could allow people to stay alive without breathing.
Amazing.
Breakthrough could change medical science by eliminating the need to keep
patients breathing during complex operations.
Okay.
So they,
the idea was this was for operations,
but it could also be used somehow or another.
You could connect to people,
some sort of a fucking thing intravenously.
And then I'll have to breathe.
Whoa.
And where is this taking place?
Where's this research research?
Uh,
that's a good question.
Maybe I shouldn't say or they'll close down on them.
He'll then a guy,
my door today,
Joe,
I got a free cytology test on my door.
Just had to fill out this 10 page thing and send it in.
And they can tell me if I'm a Scientology ready.
It says,
are you curious about you?
Yeah.
Wow.
And the questions are like,
do you often make thoughtless remarks or accusations which he later regret?
Yes or no?
Definitely.
There's just tons of questions,
like ridiculous questions to say.
Yes,
that's my whole career on podcasts.
Do you spend much time on needless worries?
Do you know?
Not really neat of us.
Not Native us.
It's his worries are legit.
He's worried about the feds coming in here.
Well,
we should be worried about
mom.
Well,
that's another thing that's been widely misreported in the news is this attack
on the u s embassy in Libya that they attributed to this fucking shitty movie
that this guy made.
And uh,
apparently that's not true at all.
And then that move,
that attack rather had been planned for a long time before that and purposely
took place on the anniversary of September 11th.
And uh,
that for some reason or another,
they decided to blame it on people reacting to this movie.
So sort of give people an irrational idea of how Muslims would respond to a,
any sort of a mocking of their faith and to get us even more,
you know,
angry at the idea of Muslims and more excited about the idea of stopping this
Muslim threat,
this Islamic threat that the world sees.
And I ran as a part of that,
you know?
Exactly.
And why didn't it,
the government come out when they knew it wasn't exactly directly a result of
that video?
Why didn't they come out and talk about that?
Right.
Yeah.
Well they don't ever was like the Pat Tillman story or the Jessica Lynch story.
When they get caught bullshitting,
they never make an okay.
We were bullshitting.
They never do that.
They just sort of
job to come forward and say that,
that this wasn't really a result of that movie.
And you didn't see that on the networks.
They didn't do that.
And instead they just continued to fill the public with this crap propaganda.
So what are you doing now as far as like broadcasting where,
where can people read your latest stuff?
Who are you working for these days?
Like how you rocking it?
What are you doing?
I uh,
I'm,
I'm working on a book.
I felt like the protests were undercovered so the first thing I did was I,
I do photography.
Um,
it's one of my loves and passions.
So I've been traveling to all these protests.
That's why we shot it in Anaheim.
And,
and taking photos of protests here in the u s and really showing people this is
happening.
And not only that people are winning,
there are,
there are people,
man,
these people down in Texas that are fighting the tar sands pipeline,
they're crazy.
These old farmers are putting devices on to attach themselves,
physically attach themselves to equipment that law enforcement has to saw off in
order to get them away.
And they're burying themselves in the ground.
Yeah.
I mean they are fighting back.
Those you don't even know about it not being covered because they're winning and
they're actually stopping this pipeline from going in or at least stopping the
construction periodically.
Um,
where is it and what is it about?
Down in Texas,
they're,
they're building a tar sands pipeline,
uh,
through some communities,
through some wineries,
some farms and,
and the community is very upset and they've really done what's called direct
action protesting,
which you can assume what that means.
That's direct action.
I mean,
they're getting in there and,
and preventing this construction from taking place.
They're also building houses.
Tree.
They're taking over trees and forests and building tree houses and having
professional climbers come in to keep that car.
I know.
You don't know.
It's fascinating.
The heart of the protest.
Um,
I,
I would say there are thousands.
I mean,
it's going on all across the state and,
and so I'm covering not only that,
I'm covering a women's right to go topless events.
There is a big event
who is fighting that there are women.
Fuck is fighting that Brian.
Not me.
Yeah.
I mean
some cities as a woman,
man,
you go out there a topless and you'll,
you'll get cuffed for a disturbing
Columbus,
Ohio.
It's uh,
it was legal to,
uh,
go outside topless,
but it was illegal to go inside a strip club and be topless,
which no existence of,
that's hilarious.
That's also strip clubs have to have bikinis yet to have a pastries.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
But you can be topless outside.
You can just walk outside.
And some guys have moves or man boobs that are bigger than the women and women,
way more disgusting.
The lookout to better areola.
Who the fuck is stopping women from going topless?
What kind of a weak ass culture?
So,
so they're winning these proteins.
These women are winning.
Like we always see,
oh,
occupied.
So stupid.
And they're not getting any change done and they're not winning.
Actually they are winning and there's a lot of cases where they have have one
and that's what this book's covering in that what else is going to Piss a lot of
people?
Well,
you're not worried about it.
This pissing people off.
You're worried about like their lily.
All right.
Now this chick is really a problem.
Um,
with NDA.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I am.
Um,
but uh,
I think a lot,
like I said,
a lot of investigative journalists are,
but it will,
it stop me.
Hell No.
It just makes me put in now and putting it now I put up that Fuck Nda,
a poster and I'm putting that one in the book,
you know?
Do you know anybody that's been put on like no fly lists or any of those things?
Yeah.
We had a one of,
even a CNN journalists you think,
oh,
they don't mess with the mainstream media.
A journalist,
a colleague of mine investigated the TSA and was put on a no fly list.
Wow.
Yeah.
For quite some time to try to intimidate him.
So if you investigate the Tsa,
they can put you on a list that says you can't fly.
Yeah.
They do that to a critical politicians and they've done it to journalists and,
and they did this to a CNN journalist.
Wow.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and as a reporter,
especially at CNN,
you need to travel.
That's your job.
You're traveling all the time.
So,
so it really affected,
so what happens when you go to the airport,
they say you can't fly.
That's it.
There's no,
you have no worries.
Of course,
I've never been on,
on the list,
but,
but I know he wasn't able to travel within the country,
so yeah.
Tell your fucking car.
So he has to go greyhound bus everywhere.
Yeah.
Or drive or what they do as they say,
they're investigating it and maybe they drag on that investigation for months
before they take your name off that list.
I haven't been put on that list yet.
Um,
but yeah,
I mean it's just big brother or trying to intimidate a descent and not only that
intimidate politicians who would be against their behavior as well as,
as journalists.
I don't think they'd mess with me because they know I would,
I would race so much hell about it.
Um,
or maybe I haven't investigated the TSA yet.
I,
uh,
that's probably why.
Wow.
What a weird,
weird world we live in.
Yeah.
I mean,
could you imagine going to the airport,
you're going to visit grandma or maybe it's an emergency,
a funeral or something and you're told you can't fly for what?
Because you're a journalist and you actually are exposing corruption in the
government,
which is our job for,
or you're Joe Rogan and you,
you got the Joe Rogan experience and you spoke out against the Tsa.
Have you ever been on a list
again and to get us in trouble?
He has too many people in here that are on the government list.
So we're going to get the list by association,
I think.
Well,
we're not doing anything.
We're just talking dude.
Yeah,
don't worry.
We're,
we're taking the easy route.
We're giving them eyes.
Is that what it is?
Or giving them the,
yeah,
the voice.
You know what I mean?
So it's like prom hard stop.
No,
it's a part of it though.
So we're probably on the list.
They're probably fine,
but we're not on the list because we get it.
We could still fly.
Sure.
Well not on that list.
We were on the Webcam.
Look at us masculine.
They like us.
That's the problem I've gotten.
I've gotten a the,
yeah,
the masturbation videos.
I make weird faces posted over it.
No good.
It was good.
Bet You want to watch.
It's worse than that.
They're good at.
I'm good.
Hear us.
You know,
if they,
that's even worse.
Not being able to see us and just hearing an go.
Okay,
so what if someone came to you and said they hacked into your computer and they
had video of you masturbating?
You guys are so,
they can't mess it up.
I'm not kidding.
I'm kidding.
Oh,
please don't put it online.
No,
it would suck.
But I wouldn't be like,
oh,
here's $1 million.
But what if they said,
okay,
you need to not have that guest on your show.
No.
Or I'm going to leak this video.
Yes,
you're going to have to have a video of me
beating off cause it's,
it's ridiculous.
It's not that big a deal.
You know?
It's like if you really want to have that video and put it out there,
first of all,
everyone's going to know that you can do that and it's going to be massive
outrage that you turn on someone for whatever reason.
You just,
you've been videotaping them beating off the whole time.
That's some UNAMERICAN bullshit right there.
That's Riddick.
It depends if there's any ass play on it,
but there always is Brian.
So why are you playing games?
Maybe.
Fuck yeah,
you're going to,
you're going to come to me with a cold sweat.
We can't have this guy on David seemed man.
Really?
We're going to do it David Seaman podcasts again.
Fuck that.
Let's get Joey d as on all the sudden if you start saying that you don't know,
someone's got a videos,
he'll be sweating and shit.
Yeah.
You're so sweaty,
man.
What's gonna be the secret word.
So you know what I'm doing.
I'm
a second.
My finger out is not fucking Weirdo.
Damn son.
Five minutes.
You know,
I was thinking of your show and okay.
Thinking on my way here of how I,
I I think that your show will go down in history as a show that told the truth
and actually had,
um,
it was,
it was a strange rise out of,
out of the mix and to something that you know,
is really becoming one of the leading voices of,
of truth and it,
when it comes to podcasts and other content and you guys are really starting to
fill that vacuum,
uh,
that has been created by the mainstream media.
Well,
it's just weird to me that there's not something like this in the mainstream
media that someone,
it's like I look at things that are fascinating to me and the world is filled
with them and some of them involve corruption and the other ones involved big
foot and crop circles and Ufos and aliens and all.
I'm interested in a lot of different things,
but it you,
you don't see a lot of discussion on these things,
whether it's an odd,
crazy things like big foot or Ufo Z,
you don't,
you don't see much real legitimate discussion about psychedelics.
You don't see much real legitimate discussion about the possible repercussions
of the way society is progressing and what is a solution to or to really teach
change the whole thing.
You don't see much legitimate discussion about that.
And I've always found that I don't,
I don't know why that exists when that's always what I would get together with
my friends and talk about when when me and my friends would be alone,
you know,
at a restaurant somewhere and someone would talk about something or Eddie Bravo
would bring up some video we saw or Brian would talk about something that was on
the Internet and,
and we would all sit around and talk about it.
I never understood why there was nothing,
no show that had these points of view.
There was no show that was like,
what is going on here where everybody seems to be pretending that everything's
fine and everybody,
everybody seems to be pretending that everything is going along,
you know,
a manageable course and we're going to be fine.
And I don't,
I don't see that.
I see madness,
I see chaos.
I see people that have way more power than they have knowledge and
enlightenment.
They have,
there's this weird sort of situation where I don't understand exactly who's
running the show and I don't think anybody does.
And then there's this dog and pony presidential debate and eventual election,
which if anything changes at all,
it'd be social issues.
You know,
that's all that ever really changed as gay marriage is the beach ball that gets
tossed back and forth and maybe medical marijuana is going to be the next one.
But Obama's already lied about that.
You know,
the,
they lied about whether or not they were going to use the DEA to go after
medical marijuana dispensary.
So I've been doing that like crazy lately.
It's it,
it's a weird thing when you realize that it doesn't matter who wins.
So weird thing
isn't it?
It's just a such a strange enlightenment to wake up and things are fine.
It doesn't matter.
I,
I've,
I've recently had that and it,
and are you going to vote
me?
I just historically speaking,
I,
I don't vote because I don't want a dog in the race.
And I know I get criticized for this all the time,
but I know if I do go in and take the time to vote for someone,
I'm going to be secretly rooting for them.
And that's a problem we're having now.
I think with people not criticizing Obama enough journalists,
because journalists tend to be more liberal and they're scared to criticize him
for Nda.
And that's why we're not seeing these vital issues covered.
So I feel like as journalists,
I feel like we shouldn't vote,
we should not have a dog in the race.
We should be able to stand back regardless of party and,
and just look for the truth and really criticized,
go after everyone.
I mean that's our job is
I say it's a piss everyone off.
That's our excuse now Brian.
No voting.
Yeah,
that's fine.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Well it keeps you on one jury duty.
No,
I encourage everyone to vote and be active.
But I as a journalist,
I encourage everybody to take mushrooms and be active that way.
Maestro and whatever way you want to.
Ryan doesn't agree with me.
I encourage ass play.
I encourage everybody to follow Amber Lyon on Twitter.
Yeah.
Amber,
l.
Y.
O.
N.
Look,
thank you very much for just being awesome.
What you've done is as very courageous and it's very rare.
It's a,
it's you've taken a very unique path and uh,
I think,
I think you're on the right side of history.
Does that make you feel good?
That means a lot.
Appreciate it.
Thank you everybody tuning in to this
fabulous podcast.
Uh,
we're not going anywhere.
You dirty bitches this weekend.
We will be in Phoenix,
Arizona at standup live.
Many of the shows are already sold out.
There's two shows.
Friday,
two shows.
Saturday one show Sunday.
Brian red band will be joining.
Holla at your boy.
Be so fun.
Yeah.
As was the ice house last night.
Thank you so much.
Everybody came out to the ice house last night.
What a fucking show.
So fun.
I mean,
the crowds that we get,
I just,
we couldn't have asked for a better,
a better thing happening.
We've could not,
there's no,
I'm not even saying us.
Right?
We couldn't have imagined that.
What's going on right now with these shows and with the podcast ever could have
happened.
It's,
it's not a call.
You guys are really nice.
The best call Deborah.
No one's running this call,
by the way.
I'm not.
I don't,
I don't know what the fuck the room,
the techs running this call with his little desk squad.
Dot.
TV.
Get yourself some Alpha brain bitch.
Enhance your neurotransmitters so you understand what the fuck we're going on.
About ants.
Yes.
And the African desert.
Get on a bitch and fall red ban on Twitter,
r e.
D.
B a n death squad.
Dot TV is where you could pick up your funky fresh kitty cat tee shirts.
There's two of them.
One of them has the hypnotic super cat on it.
That's what I'm calling the new one,
the hypnotic supercat.
I love that fucking cat who,
and the guy just got a tattoo of it very recently.
Yeah.
Congratulations.
Sorry.
You made an excellent choice.
Yeah,
thanks to [inaudible] dot com for sponsoring us as well.
Go to o n n I t and use the code name Brogan.
You will save 10% off any and all supplements.
Did you just slow it down?
Slow it down at the end?
What are you doing?
You're mixing?
Yeah.
Okay.
That's it.
Folks fucking shows over.
It doesn't get any better than this.
This is all we got for yet,
but we love,
yeah,
we love the shit out of you and we'll see you soon.